so I I guess Elon Musk is buying Twitter
and uh he filed to close the deal at the
original price which is kind of weird
because after all the fighting he just
said all right yeah I'll buy it for what
I agreed to buy it for and then Twitter
has formally responded saying okay we're
gonna sell and now apparently there are
messages being posted anonymously by
Twitter staff freaking out because well
here we go so I don't know what else to
add to the story because it's just like
an echo of the story that already
happened back in when was this like
April or something Elon announced he's
gonna buy the platform all these woke
journalists and leftists are screaming
like no we'll lose control of the
narrative and then Elon says I don't
want to buy it then they'll start
laughing saying haha you're not going to
buy it now he's buying it and their
brains are exploding but here's where it
gets crazy
Elon could own Twitter within 72 hours
they're going to finalize the deal and
it could be done and then I certainly
hope the moment he signs the paperwork
he goes okay now reinstate Trump I just
that that's just there you go and
there's a handful of other people we got
to get Carl Benjamin back on the
platform he's a good friend and we and
and he deserves to be back on the
platform as well as many other people
you know you've mentioned Molly not
milianopolis uh Laura Loomer among many
others Alex Jones so uh it should be
interesting so we'll talk about that but
the reasons as to why Elon Musk is doing
this are interesting a lot of people are
saying it's because he was going to lose
this lawsuit anyway but I wonder if it
has something to do with another story
Elon Musk said that Bots were piling on
his polls when he was calling for peace
in Ukraine I wonder if this was a
catalyst seeing a bunch of bots advocate
for what is potentially world war three
and he was like okay we're gonna buy
Twitter and just finally put an end to
this like this was the straw on the
Campbell's back so we're going to talk
about all of that my friends but before
we get started head over to
surfinginternetsafe.com and download
virtual Shield a virtual private network
service again surfing internetsafe.com a
VPN is a basic layer of security for you
as you browse the web so if you're
worried about government hackers or
corporations or just your isps stealing
your data and selling it a VPN is a good
way to keep yourself safe as you browse
the web go to surfinginternetsafe.com
and they and they say over at virtual
Shield their VPN is compatible with all
devices and allows you to browse the web
safely securely and anonymously using
their Global Network of servers and
private isps when using their VPN
service your traffic is routed through
their secure and encrypted servers that
means that any restrictions censorship
or blocks on your internet are bypassed
it's completely free for 30 days works
on Mac Windows iPhone iPad Android or
Chrome does all the work for you all you
got to do is download it click the
button go and then you're good
virtual Shield routes your internet
through their Advanced encrypted servers
across the globe preventing isps from
tracking you as you surf the web and
it'll actually encrypt your Wi-Fi
connection as well they got a bunch of
plans personal family and business plans
family plans include 15 devices and the
business plan allows you to add as many
employees as you need virtual Shield
thank you so much for supporting the
show they've been supporting us the
first sponsor we've ever had go to
surfinginternetsafe.com get your VPN
today but don't forget to also go to
timcast.com become a member because
we're going to have a members only show
coming up tonight at 11 PM it's the
uncensored members only after a show and
as a member you're keeping our
journalists and reporters gainfully
employed we have people on the ground
reporting we have people writing every
single day we could use your support
don't forget to also smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show right now with your friends be
the notification a lot of people are
saying the notifications aren't being
sent out right before the midterm
surprise surprise so take the URL post
it anywhere and be that notification
joining us we got a couple people
joining us today talk about this and
more we have Josie the red-headed
libertarian hi buddy it's great to be
here
who are you I have the redheaded
libertarian uh you can find me at
t-r-h-l-official on Twitter
um and I just I like the Constitution I
talk about that a lot I just
I I like to be silly
um you get a mixed bag with me I have a
fancy cat his name's Figaro
um so those are those are kind of kind
of the the big points yes well all right
thanks for joining us and we also have
Corey DeAngelis yeah I'm in Ian's spot
now and and this is kind of interesting
he has a lot of stuff going on over here
there's like some toilet paper I don't
know I I have lots of questions that's
actually Luke's what are you doing over
there that's not me that's on the inside
of the table okay but yes Corey
DeAngelis I'm a senior fellow at the
American Federation for children it's
good to be here I'm a school choice
Advocate and that's uh basically what I
do I might have some competition here
with Josie but that's another topic here
anyway my name is Luke radowski if we
are changed at Oregon today I'm
definitely wearing my free as a bird
sure yeah that's the official name of it
with of course Elon Musk smoking a
doobie inside of the Twitter logo which
you could exclusively get as a member of
lucancenter.com for the cost of its
production and because you do that
that's why I'm here thank you so much
for having me I want that shirt I'm
pretty jealous yeah you can order it so
that you can order from Luke because
Luke is our humble t-shirt salesman we
keep on hand I'm competing for crazy
shirt mine's brighter than his the his
is more topical than mine I'm excited
for tonight's conversation let's get
into it here we go from Engadget Twitter
confirms it intends to close deal with
Elon Musk Twitter has again agreed to
let Elon Musk buy the company they say
the agreement follows months of legal
drama after musk tried to back out of
his original agreement to buy the
company for 44 billion dollars this
spring the two sides were set to go to
trial later this month as Twitter
attempted to force Moss to keep up his
under the agreement Muscat claims
Twitter had missed led him about the
number of bots on the platform and had
raised concerns about issues disclosed
by the company's former head of security
who fell The Whistleblower complaint
so Twitter investor relations tweets
Twitter issued this statement about
today's news we have received a letter
from the musk parties which they have
filed with the SEC the intention of the
company is to close the transaction at
fifty four dollars and 20 cents per
share the question
why did Elon Musk try backing out
go into this big legal drama and then
abruptly just agree to the original sale
price I mean my my attitude was couldn't
he have at least tried to to lower the
price like oh okay we're gonna go to
core it's gonna be a waste of time how
about we do 50 bucks per share call it a
day they Pro Twitter would probably have
been like okay fine just well if you
agree to that then we're gonna get an
approval from the show and then we're
done instead he just comes out yeah it's
good just full thing whatever why what's
what's going on here was it because he
was embarrassed by the leaked text
messages or what
uh I I'm an optimist I think he wanted
to expose the Bots
um and why why back out why why yeah
well there's a number of theories the
corporate media is running with a theory
that he was hiding from disclosure that
already the text messages that were
released were allegedly embarrassing and
that he didn't want more disclosure
that's one of the theories that's out
there by the corporate media that
they're counting Counting is the truth
uh but but I think personally I I think
a lot of it had to do with the spat that
he had with the Ukrainian president
especially with him trying to offer some
kind of negotiation or peace deal bring
that conversation to the Forefront where
he was dogpiled by the NPCs and by the
corporate establishment that of course
punished him and and and tried to make
him seem like a bad guy because he was
trying to prevent a nuclear war so that
to me was just absurge to see that kind
of conversation unfold with zelinski's
advisor literally sending out a photo of
him photoshopped as a Ukrainian Trader
that's crazy in handcuffs but I mean
come on Luke guys you agree with me
right there's too many people nuclear
war would be a good thing just too many
of them okay Bill Gates Jr there
this is another thing to understand here
around the the Elon Musk Ukraine
controversy because Elon Musk provided
Ukraine with starlink which a lot of
military analysts and experts are saying
is one of the reasons why ukrainians are
having such major victories inside of
this larger proxy war between Russia
because of the GPS satellite tracking
the Weapons Systems all depend on the
internet and the Google CEO Eric Schmidt
former Google CEO who's also working on
the Pentagon lead defense Innovation
board came out and said that Elon Musk
is the true hero when it comes to the
war in Ukraine so to have the Ukrainian
president who has to have his advisors
to have the Ukrainian people lash out at
him and punish him when he already
contributed so much to the Ukrainian
people for this conflict is is really
something that I think might have hurt
Elon Musk and might have added to this
larger decision vision for him to buy
Twitter since of course he was painted
as the boogeyman as the bad guy for
trying to prevent a nuclear war yeah
diplomacy nowadays so rare that they
frame it as treason
yeah I mean look I'm really happy about
Elon Musk buying Twitter finally I think
I've been waiting for this for a long
time
um but you know he is kind of the bad
guy because I've lost like 2 500
followers within the past day so he has
some explaining to do I don't know why a
lot of us I think here and Spike Cohen
um the VP candidate for the libertarian
party in 2020 tweeted out that he had
lost 2 000 followers too so I don't know
what the theory is for why that's
happening perhaps Twitter's cleaning up
all the Bots and and hiding that so that
when uh Elon Musk takes control I gotta
look under the hood and I got two
conspiracy theories for you one is
anti-elon one is pro Elon all right
we'll start with the anti-elon one first
Elon Musk announces he wants to buy
Twitter because he really does he says
I'm gonna buy it at 54 a share he then
tries to back out and plays this big
game which ultimately saw Twitter stock
drop down into like the mid 30s or
something like this
one of the things we heard with this
deal Elon is going to some of the other
investors like that that uh there was
that that Saudi Prince I think and he's
telling them use like vote to let this
go private keep your shares I'm gonna
I'm gonna buy up uh you know as much as
I can and then you can keep yours if you
agree to take the company private
because I'm going to fix it and then
when it goes public again your stocks
are going to be worth way way more
so the idea is he doesn't need to buy
every single share from every single
person if he can work out these
agreements with the big investors so the
stock price drops 35. a bunch of people
hearing the news is going to do this
start buying up stock at the cheap price
thinking oh maybe I'll get a chance to
hold on to this when it goes private
because you know then once it goes
public again I'll make a bunch of money
and Elon then basically knows if a ton
of people buy at the low rate agree with
them and take it private
he doesn't need to buy their shares it's
going to save him a ton of money now I
don't know if that if that if that's
possible if it makes sense uh I was
talking to Will Chamberlain about he
says he says no I was talking to him in
the context of he does this his buddies
buy up from people at 35 bucks then you
know knowing they're not going to have
to sell to Elon that them holding it
basically allows them to take it private
and he said it's a really bad time to
try and do any kind of financial
malfeasance because you're under such
scrutiny but maybe maybe that's why I
said conspiracy theory here's the other
one Elon Musk was talking about Bots
Luke pointed this out he was saying you
know hey vote on this should Ukraine
offer up some kind of peace agreement he
was saying that um there's people of
Ukraine vote but notice in the U.N
should oversee the Don bass region
elections and then Crimea should be
returned to Russia as you know it's been
for a long time and then the Ukrainian
started attacking him he gets dogpiled
the originally the poll says yes let's
have peace but then all sudden it flips
to no no peace no agreement Elon says
the Bots came out in force for this one
I'm wondering if that was it I mean look
this he he was he's been playing games
this this lawsuit for a long time he if
he was really concerned with the lawsuit
wouldn't he have just conceded a long
time ago so I'm wondering if he saw this
and he got really really pissed off at a
bunch of bots voting to say yes to
potentially nuclear World War III and
he's like I'm buying it and he's gonna
go in because Bots are what he's been
complaining about for the longest time
and he's just gonna just wipe the Slate
on all these Bots and then he's gonna
bring Donald Trump back
do you think Donald Trump will hurt or
help the stock price oh he'll help it
he'll help it yeah he was their bread
and butter before when he had an account
yeah but I don't think Trump would do it
I don't think Trump will come back no
because it'll be social but it's not
just that it's like don't they have dwac
or whatever Trump World acquisition Corp
like you know Digital World acquisition
Corp or something like that well Trump
also made a public statement saying I
don't want to be back on Twitter I won't
be back on Twitter even if Elon Musk
buys Twitter he said this a couple
months ago I don't know if his opinion
changed especially with you know all the
presidential races I I think you know we
understand the importance of of big Tech
social media so those Elon Musk and
there was a couple of things leading up
to this before the whole spite between
Ukraine and Elon Musk he sent out a meme
a couple days ago that said those who
don't study history or doomed to repeat
it yet those who do study history are
doomed to stand by helplessly while
everyone else repeats it so oh man him
after posting that Meme came up with a
proposition to bring peace to Ukraine it
wasn't a perfect proposition but at
least the conversation started there
hasn't been a conversation on peace
deals there have been a lot of peace
deals offered that were very close to
being achieved especially one by turkey
especially one that the ukrainians and
Russians agreed to Western Powers said
no Western media is saying no peace and
their strategy here isn't really a smart
one it's let's let's push Putin into a
corner that's phase one phase two phase
three we don't know what that is yet but
let's just let's just escalate the
situation and it's mind-boggling it's so
crazy that that out of everything that's
happening right now hey we have a
situation that is bringing us on the
brink of nuclear war hey let's repeat
those same policies and double down on
them it is exactly the Underpants Gnomes
where they have the the one like we're
gonna do this and then the next line is
the question marks and then the final
line is profit yeah step one still still
Underpants step two question mark step
three profits exactly that's one so I I
was you know I was thinking about this
with um you know nuclear war and how
they're really really advocating for
this conflict they really don't want any
kind of settlement Arrangement and I was
thinking also about you know
depopulation conspiracies and things
like that and you know what I I like to
say is the only difference between
what's actually happening in a
conspiracy theory is the conspiracy
theory implies intent if you remove the
the hypothesis of intent from an
individual you no longer have a
conspiracy theory you have literally
what's happening so for example what's
going on with everything on the left
telling Farmers how to farm is a food
shortage sterilizing kids aborting kids
um advocating War whether they if you
want to say it's because they intend to
reduce the population okay that's a
conspiracy theory if you say I don't
know why they're doing it but the end
result is the reduction of population
well that's literally what's happening
so I thought about something interesting
I have a series of tweets that I tweet
frequently where I just you know I I say
some I tweet things that I kind of feel
are like they should be cancelable
things like like I tweeted several times
have you considered spaying and
neutering your kids to prevent
overpopulation and I've tweeted things
like the the upside to abortion is that
there's too many children and we need
less people on the planet like these
should be things that ever like anyone
ever said seriously people should be
like whoa whoa whoa come on but there's
not not only does it break no rules on
Twitter to ask people to like consider
sterilizing their children
there's no outrage from the media at all
I was thinking about this I was like I
bet if I tweet things like war is good
because there's too many people they
will they will completely ignore it if I
tweet it's great that children are being
sterilized they'll completely lo and
behold the media doesn't care one bit
there's no smears no cancellation I just
I don't know what their intent is but
for whatever reason everything is
pointing in One Direction these actions
will result in much less people
have you ever been suspended for
anything like that or any of the tweets
removed
have you ever been suspended from
Twitter or I've been locked out
um when they banned the the groomer
stuff they retroactively enforce it
against me and so I had to delete the
tweet and I'm like I don't care about
Twitter like people are like leave your
messages up I'm like dude it's Twitter
I'll just say something else weird I
don't know so I just took him down you
gotta misspell it that's the trick ah
yeah yeah writing code so you can just
keep changing the word it's like Grovers
yep exactly so like taking a step back I
mean Elon Musk started this whole
conversation about acquiring Twitter
because he said it was so important it's
the public sphere we have to have great
um discussion it's it's how we uphold
democracy
um why not why not buy the whole school
system and uh put you know have a better
investment because we have millions of
kids going to government schools where
they're being indoctrinated to think
like socialists when they grow up and I
think that's even more detrimental to
society than the public sphere when it
comes to Twitter the thing is the public
school system is way too expensive Elon
Musk abology no no I mean imagine what
you could buy with 44 billion dollars
how many politicians could you get in
your lap how many of them can you have
barking and jumping up and down when you
tell them to jump I think all of them
you have enough money you could have
done that but but I think he also
understands that that big Tech social
media is is a power that is even beyond
the US government when it comes to
flexing its ability to influence society
and you could even see through the
disclosures through the text messages
that were received him saying quote he
wants to reign in big Tech these are the
words of Elon Musk from the text
messages that were released he's saying
quote our Public Square needs not to
have arbitrary sketch censorship and
that quote we have right now what we
have right now is hidden corruption
we're allowed uh we're allowed to do
this segment right now this next one
we've earned it and we are now going to
gloat over the Twitter employees who are
losing their minds so mediaite reports
Twitter employees explode over musk deal
cue the layoffs maybe I bet a lot of
these people are going to quit Daniel
Sullivan says the reaction from Twitter
employees on team blind an app that
allows people at different companies to
post anonymously is something to behold
here's one
so we've got an angry triggered
billionaire going to own us who's
looking for vengeance the worst
Financial Market in years hiring freezes
everywhere Q4 is looking great
to our employees heard the news the
latest development in musk's potential
purchase while they were in a meeting
discussing the company's goals in 2023
living the plot of succession is effing
exhausting rum and chattery Twitter's
director of machine learning ethics
transparency accountability tweeted in
reaction to the musk news
Daniel Sullivan said this Twitter
employee sums up what I'm hearing from
folks inside the company today and uh
that's too bad
E.J Simpson says I encourage every
Twitter employee to go outside and take
a walk yes never boring over here yeah
congratulations to our employees you
know it's just the weirdest thing the
cult is the weirdest thing to me you
know they they just
in order to be in this cult you have to
not read the news ever
and so we'll get into this a little bit
but I was talking about BLM and Kanye
West earlier on my other show and if you
look at Democrats or if you look at 18
or 35 year olds they have tremendous net
support for BLM and then you look at
every other demographic and it's just
like underwater independent voters it's
net a negative 12 net support uh only
Democrats support them and I'm like it's
the perfect example these people are
freaking out because the only way the
cult exists is that they they isolate
people from information the only reason
why these young people support BLM is
because they don't read the news they're
more subject driven and not object
driven so you get older you start
focusing more on your family you start
reading the news and seeing what's going
on in the world and you say oh okay
here's what's happening when you're
younger you're like what are my friends
doing what are my friends talking about
and your friends will just all repeat
whatever lies are filtered to them this
is obviously why these people are in
particular well they're losing their
minds over this the cult is going to
implode without Twitter I mean they
needed they have Tumblr I guess you know
but I don't know how much that how how
much that's going to do for them well
it's funny watching these people just
switch like uh immediately the same
people saying oh Twitter's a private
company they could do whatever they want
you you every yeah
what did we do no no not that now you
have uh proposals from the White House
right uh calling to um censor the
internet yeah AI Bill of Rights yeah
that's what they came out with uh the
hill did an article on this today who
was it Democrats uh the white house so
I'm guessing yes whoever's whoever works
there who really knows this is basically
you can't you can't get banned yeah yeah
you have the right to a person as
opposed to an algorithm like that it's
just a list it's a proposal you know
that's going to go through well it's
funny how it switches like almost
immediately yeah yeah our people aren't
in charge anymore
okay exactly so obviously a lot of
people at Twitter will be scrambling
with this news today according to the
New York Post uh 68 of Twitter employees
disapprove of musk and his vision for
Twitter and for what he sees for the
company that especially wants to make
sure that people are going to be at uh
the workplace and not just doing all the
work at home but but it's not just
Twitter employees that are going to be
scrambling here it's also a lot of
government officials who are now going
to be like okay now we have to prevent
this from happening because once you
open the floodgates of free speech you
have the potential of really making the
world a better place you have the
potential of exposing a lot of sinister
nefarious things in our existence that
could be stopped through transparency
and accountability the government is
deathly afraid of this and I I could
imagine I could see new rules new
regulations when it comes to social
media as already they have a lot of
secret orders they have a lot of secret
actions that they take part in as we
recently learned from Alex Berenson that
they are the ones the federal government
government the White House ordering the
censorship of political voices of
scientists of Doctors medical
professionals and even members and
individuals who of course do parody
accounts of Dr fauci have all had their
accounts shut down because the federal
government and the Biden Administration
said no we can't allow this which is
absolutely crazy they're not going to be
able to censor those New York posts
articles well Elon Musk also a couple
days ago was interacting with the CEO of
Rumble and he was showing interest in
working with Rumble before this major
acquisition of Twitter which he now has
announced as of today so there's also
that as well there is something called
the Twitter trusted partnership and
Twitter partner support portal that
allows the government to issue
censorship orders Twitter agreed to
comply with this to avoid a regulatory
oversight there's a wow there's an art
this was a few years ago where this
happened and it was there's one
newspaper that covered it because
nobody's going to talk about that it was
the NC Daily Gazette
um yeah the question I guess is Will
these woke people stay on Twitter
because their argument is if Elon buys
Twitter we're leaving it's like oh yeah
where where are you going where you're
going to go Facebook I mean
yeah they go somewhere else I mean that
the um Amazon and Google will allow it
unlike with the Parlor right right
um yeah but mastodon's been around for a
while and it's got It's like it's very
very leftist version of Twitter it's so
woke that when um who's that guy who
played that that annoying kid on Star
Trek that everybody will Will Wheaton
there you go yeah yeah even when he left
Twitter and went there they banned him
oh like that's how that's how woke and
far left there they were like no Will
Wheaton you're a fascist and he's like
an annoying liberal dude so I mean they
tried it didn't work yeah I think it's
going to be a dramatic shift there's one
dude from NBC who's claiming
this is funny this tweet where he's like
now that they're going private the rules
can be whatever they want and it's just
like you've literally been advocating
for that the whole time that's literally
what they do but what they're really
showing is that they are terrified they
have lost control of the narrative
machine and the crazy thing about it is
Elon Musk isn't even proposing to go
into Twitter and ban left ban the left
this is what they're arguing they're
like Trump's gonna uh they're they're
like elon's gonna be de-platforming
people and banning leftists it's like
literally the opposite of everything is
advocated for it yeah it is not going to
do that at all he wants to bring the
people back who've been unfairly banned
well that's the problem I guess the left
is like when we get power we will
destroy you and when the right gets
power they're like no no we'll be fair
yeah we'll do what you want yeah we'll
we'll leave it how dare you
well even in the disclosures of Elon
musk's test text messages there's one
conversation he had with an anonymous
Twitter employee that's not named
because of the quote sensitive nature of
the conversation the sensitive nature of
this conversation was quote how to
navigate how to let right Wingers back
on Twitter so so this is this is an
official text message that was happening
between Elon Musk and an employee at
Twitter that's that's Anonymous that's
that's pretty big
um I could send you the the copy of it
right now or I could just tweet it out
right now but the DMS and and the
private messages some of them are leaked
and people could read them online and
they really do tell a very interesting
tale of what's Happening behind the
scenes here we need to get a a video
ready of like Trump suiting up like
putting his shoes on and then walking
and straightening his tie he's like I'm
back I'm that's all I care about you
know bring Trump back because there were
so many journalists when he got banned
there were these threads where
journalists were like I would have to
have my phone on alert because it was my
job and so I would get an alert at three
in the morning they'd like my boss would
be calling me being like Trump tweeted
write it up and they'd be like it's
three in the morning this is one of the
reasons I think so many journalists
probably hated Trump because he would
tweet at like 2 A.M yeah they'd have to
wake up and then be like write the story
like Trump says something about North
Korea I don't know what's going on and
then everybody's like I wish the guy was
would just play ball and just do what
he's told instead he
pisses off all these journalists so they
just write lies about him endlessly
I think a lot of Twitter is a consensus
between the Bots between the bands of
the right wing people
um it's it's about
finding consensus so when people who
aren't that same thing with you know you
have the media you have Hollywood you
have big Tech you have uh the the
corporate press you have the the the
government the career politicians you
have socialism everywhere it's
everywhere and I think a lot of that is
about consensus and it's so when
somebody who's maybe an armchair you
know they vote you know so they're going
to go and they're going to research and
they're going to find everybody thinks
this way nobody thinks that way so that
way must be bad you know so that's
that's my ideas that they use Twitter
kind of as a machine for consensus I
mean it'll be interesting to see what
happens with these elections coming up
in November uh with Elon Musk If he if
he takes over by then and I'm already
getting messages I was scrolling through
Facebook today uh notifications and they
were saying well we're gonna you know
there's gonna be I didn't read through
all of it but it seemed like they were
priming you to be ready for censored
content when the election comes up and
so it's like they're already sending us
warnings like there's going there's
something's coming yeah Josie you're
definitely right and I would even go
further absolutely big Tech social media
is used as a tool not just for consensus
but for manipulation and there are Bots
there's a lot of bots there's a lot of
sock puppet accounts there's a lot of
government officials the Israeli
government even announced this 15 years
ago that they're hiring individuals to
set consensus online to of course spread
the messaging that's more favorable
towards their government if you think
the US government is not doing this if
you think the Chinese government and the
Russian government is not doing this
you're absolutely kidding yourself and
there's a lot of bots it's estimated
according through a lot of uh
accounting that that you know a lot of
the most popular accounts have the most
amount of bots since Bots are you say
following those accounts like Biden is
expected According to some estimates
having at least 49.3 percent of his
entire Twitter followers to be Bots to
be fake so so when you look at the
consensus and when you look at what
people really think and you look at the
reality on Twitter it's a totally
different reality uh there's a Quincy
poll showing how the majority of
Americans 50 57 percent of them want
negotiations want to end the war in
Ukraine as soon as possible but that
wasn't reflected in the Elon Musk poll
that he did asking uh around the similar
question of of Peace in Ukraine so
what's really going on here obviously
there's a lot of manipulation behind the
scene that we don't even know about war
is very profitable people incredibly
profitable so we have
a recession you know so they're not
fixing that they're making it worse how
could they fix it with a snap of a
fingers War yep let's jump to this next
story from the whitehouse.gov blueprint
for an AI Bill of Rights making
automated systems work for the American
people excellent I think it's a lot of
nothing to be honest I was I was looking
at it just for a little bit and uh let's
just talk about what their what their uh
proposal is did it and this was released
today the same day Elon
um came out and said he's gonna buy
that's right safe and effective systems
algorithmic discrimination protections
data privacy notice and explanation
human Alternatives consideration and
fallback now I don't know these are kind
of like nebulous terms but some of it's
actually I agree with safe and effective
systems automated systems should be
developed with consultation from diverse
communities stakeholders take a look at
that what does that word mean Luke
what stakeholder stakeholders you know
people who have stakes and they eat them
and they hold they're holding the stuff
people love skin in the game I'm gonna
give you one more chance Luke now you
don't know go ahead the people who of
course are are it's the world yeah
investors controllers centralizers new
new it's their no it means you the world
like in my Forum says we have to move
Beyond shareholders and move towards
stakeholder economy which is who is it
who is affected by this as opposed to
who owns it so this is basically World
economic Forum Davos type language and
um you know yeah language is a domain
experts identify concerns risk potential
impacts in the systems blah blah blah
blah blah look I I agree you know Ian's
brought this up if you don't know what
an algorithm is doing to you like when
Facebook was experimenting on people we
got a problem and they shouldn't be
allowed to do that the next one's
actually really interesting algorithmic
discrimination protections they say you
should not face discrimination by
algorithms and systems should be used
and designed in an equitable way oh here
we go Equitable exciting but here's the
interesting thing they say you can't be
discriminated on the basis of race color
ethnicity sex pregnancy childbirth
medical conditions and identity intersex
status religion age national origin
disability veteran status genetic
information or any other classification
protected by law full stop that's a very
very Broad and bold thing to say what
does that mean protected by a lot
there's a bunch of different places in
this country that have different
parameters for the human rights law
notably Washington DC which says
political affiliation is a protected
class right if they're going to claim
anything protected by law well then all
certain DC it is does that mean if they
were to implement these policies if you
live in DC could you sue if you were
banned for political reasons um that's
interesting thing is that a States right
thing didn't DeSantis do something like
that in Florida where uh if you are
running for office and you get banned
you can sue I can't remember exactly
what it was he did something like that
on a state level
yeah the thing is though the defense
will just be well we banned them for
something else right instead of
political reasons but then even if it's
it's not working because as we saw at
Alex Berenson when he sued I guess the
ruling was they have to explain what
they did because you have a contract
with them so like
you know I can put in a contract I have
I can terminate this contract for these
specific reasons what Twitter does
Twitter says we can ban you for these
reasons and so if they ban you and it's
for a reason they have to explain
exactly what they did I suppose there's
an argument that they say we can ban you
for any reason or no reason but there
was a new I think it was a fifth Circuit
Court ruling where the judge said no
they can't these big platforms can't
just ban you arbitrarily they don't have
the right to do that so that'll be
interesting to see how that gets
adjudicated as it makes a way to the
Supreme Court
because that's not actually a contract
if they could do that I mean wouldn't
that be some sort of violation what am I
thinking would it be some sort of
violation if they can just change their
rules and ban you as they go and change
the rules if you if you get on Twitter
in 2010 and then they've changed the
rules change the rules change the rules
like are you agreeing to all those
changes this is a big thing with patreon
there was like there was a lawsuit and
patreon abruptly changed their rules and
tried to get everyone to agree to the
new rules without because they don't
know what it is and it was because it
was gonna the the suit required them to
go to arbitration and they had to pay
the cost of arbitration so if like a
million people Sue they gotta pay you
know 100 million dollars for some
ridiculous amount so they tried changing
the rules and the judge was like when
these people signed up
they sign up and agreed under these
terms and the action you took which
violated the terms happened before you
changed the contract so we are going to
operate under the previous rules I don't
know where that case ended up going but
this is interesting because
I believe big Tech platforms should not
have the right to just ban you for no
reason that should be stricken as just
like not applicable oh and so the the
example I'll give you is we need to
treat we need to start treating this all
like like being a tenant a landlord or
like your the big Tech platforms are
landlords renting you space in exchange
for something in this case for Twitter
it's by you being in the platform they
can sell advertisements so there's a net
there's an exchange good there's an
exchange here
imagine a landlord was like you can live
in this building the rent is 2500 bucks
a month and you're like okay now here's
the reasons I can evict you if you smash
the windows if you're throwing food out
the window if you're too noisy and you
won't stop and also for literally any
reason at any time
yeah no no court is going to pull that
they're back you can't do that there's
laws so I view this stuff like no no no
Twitter YouTube Facebook they don't get
to say we're going to enter in to a
monetization contract where you can
start a business you can monetize the
pla monetize yourself on this platform
we are going to monetize you but we can
terminate the contract at any reason
with with no no I think imagine if the
world operated this way like you go to a
landlord in in downtown of your city and
you're like I'm gonna open a bakery and
they say okay so long as you're not
making like swastika cupcakes I don't
care you're fine and then one day for no
reason he says you know you uh you know
you made mint chocolate chip cupcakes
and I hate it so I'm kicking you out I
don't got to give you a reason how could
businesses survive if landlords could
just terminate a business like that with
no argument with no with no lawsuit now
that most businesses are moving online
now that tons of people make their
living on the internet we absolutely
have to today ensure protections for
people as if they're a tenant I agree
with that because I went through it
um right after the uh right after not
after the election but after the
um when Biden got into office January
21st I ended up getting banned from
Twitter and I was never told why I was
just banned arbitrarily banned and I was
gone until
uh the last week in April this year when
Elon said he was going to buy Twitter
and I miraculously reappeared
um and but that was a really tough
because you know I had like kind of
built this brand and I I was you know
like growing and I was spreading a
message and I was just gone one day and
I I was no longer in the Public Square
and no I didn't do anything wrong and
did they give you a message or no just
like you you violated terms and you can
appeal this so I appealed it and then
they were like you know three months
later they're like no no now you're now
you're permanently suspended and I'm
like
that's what you get for appealing I know
right like yeah so so it was just it was
it was really difficult you know to be
kicked out of the Public Square I mean
I'm just I I don't post anything that
bad I don't think but
um yeah so I've lived through it I am
absolutely an advocate for
an AI Bill of Rights you know I know why
they're doing about this one now now I
don't know about this one I haven't read
through the whole thing yet but this one
I mean the timing of it with who gets to
make enforce this AI Bill of Rights and
a lot of the language is very broad you
know so so I would have to take a closer
look at it but there are points that I
do agree with in there like the Arbiter
Banning of why whatever you know but but
of course that's not going to be in
there and you should never trust the
government oh God and you should never
trust the government ever if they use
broad generalized language because they
will use it for their own personal
interest and they have been manipulating
social media for their own personal
benefit already in such an extensive
bastardized way that it's sickening to
most people yeah I agree with this one
right here human Alternatives it says
you should be able to opt out where
appropriate and have access to a person
who can quickly consider and remedy
problems you encounter that would grow
jobs too because nobody works at Twitter
exactly it's just too big yeah but my my
response would that be a regulation to
force Twitter to have a bunch of human
customer service agents yeah is that
what that is and considering their
profits are in the billions they can
afford to hire a lot of customer service
agents
though but but what they usually do is
they they Outsource it they go to places
like Africa they go to places in Asia
and they get cheap labor markets to do a
lot of the Banning and censoring and
there was even a controversy with one
big Tech social media company hiring a
specific group of people that that hated
uh people for their uh you know
sexuality and they they went on a purge
Banning people and there was no way to
get any justice from it because there's
no way of contacting Google and being
like hey uh why did I get banned can I
talk to somebody can I please have some
kind of way to have some accountability
here none of that I'm just I'm just
concerned that this only uh helps
Twitter keep their market share in the
big providers uh it could be a barrier
to entry requiring additional costs to
enter
the market and start up a new social
media platform I mean it is it is it is
it is a problem that you have companies
that say we're not I mean look if if you
start a company that people are signing
up for and then they encounter a problem
that breaches the contract and you say
I'm not going to remedy that then they
sue you and I suppose the issue is poor
people can't afford to sue so what
companies just get away with screwing
over customers you like imagine if this
is a brick and mortar store and you and
customers came in and said how do I
return this product it was defective you
could say we actually don't have any
customer service you can email us I mean
that's that's not okay so maybe it's
going to bake costs into things but
there you you need to be able to remedy
your problems with it with a human being
and I think I don't know about Twitter
because Twitter is garbage and there's
too many people on it one of the issues
is that the value of an individual is
not great enough to Warrant the cost of
a customer service rep this is one of
the problems with the massive user base
of these platforms and also of you know
governance in the United States 770 000
people per congressional district you
can't even and address all the issues of
every single person you get someone on
Facebook
and they're I think I think a Twitter
user's value is like two dollars
and so how many Twitter users do you
need to cover the cost per year of one
employee
so that is that employee able to
actually address all of the concerns and
issues that's not not going to happen I
do think one of the biggest problems
with all these platforms is that they
keep catering to these whiny babies now
let's do another brick and mortar you
know uh analogy imagine you own a
cupcake shop and there's a dude sitting
there talking with his buddies minding
his own business in the corner and he's
talking about how he voted for Donald
Trump so some other guy on the other
side gets up and says kick him out now
Karen and yeah and they're like why
because he is saying hateful things
Donald Trump is a racist and they're
like okay sir you have to leave because
you've upset this person he's like what
what did I do like well you were saying
things that upset him so get out how are
you supposed to function as a business
like that it should be the other way
around if you've got a problem you can
leave here's your cupcake bye-bye
there's the door this dude's minding his
own business system is it's it's I just
don't see how this works granted I think
the White House AI stuff is some people
are matching in the chat they're trying
to save themselves because they know
Elon is going to come in and take
control of the narrative exactly that's
why the timing I was like soon as I saw
that why did they shot the Chaser
exactly well he also talked about
opening up the algorithm so it allows
people to see what they're actually
subscribed to a crazy idea as of course
we are ruled by algorithms that that not
only control what we see but also sensor
content arbitrarily not on Fair rules as
we learned recently there's a certain
rules for very famous people and there's
a certain rule for people who don't have
as many followers people who don't have
as much influence who of course get
punished more this was specifically uh
detailed with Facebook who of course get
to play by different set of rules so
that's a completely unfair system it's
not just there's no clear rules and I
think they want no rules so you have to
live in fear so you have to think twice
before you post anything so you have to
worry hey will I lose my ability to to
have a voice in our conversation in in
in in the National dialogue if I if I
dare talk about this idea This Is How
They Roll they rule through fear and
censorship which is absolutely a
disgusting abuse of power they want
there to be no rules no uh well Elon
Musk specifically talked about opening
up the the source code and the algorithm
where people get to see what they're
subscribed to see he also talked about
rules especially when it comes to adult
content especially when it comes to
Illegal content that is already illegal
in the United States and punishable uh
with you know a law enforcement stepping
in and punishing people for saying and
doing certain things so obviously there
are some rules here but when it comes to
an algorithm where you see exactly what
you're subscribed to see I think that's
a that's an amazing thing that made the
internet so popular in the first place I
wonder aside from the fact that um a lot
of the
um people with the larger followings are
protected I wonder if that also has to
do with ads they're going to sell more
ads because these people have or there's
going to get more viewership to the ads
on the accounts of uh the larger
followings
I think they do a cost benefit analysis
and they say
if we ban ex-people
how many followers will leave for those
people being banned and then how much
revenue do we lose and they ultimately
determine you know what the left is more
cantankerous than the right
if we ban someone on the left they get
really really mad and they lose their
minds and then they threaten boycotts
and they organize boycotts the right
doesn't they won't even take off work to
go protest the left will so the the the
the the cost benefit analysis is simple
you ban someone on the right you're
going to lose money but you'll lose more
money if you don't Pander to the left so
that's what they do although
surprisingly because I'd imagine a lot
of people on the left don't have a lot
of money but I guess it's skus it's like
on the right you have more working
people more middle class people on the
left you have wealthier people so it's
like
we only need to keep a hundred thousand
wealthy Democrats happy on Twitter but
we have to keep a million Republicans
happy to to get the same level of you
know you know buying purchasing power so
it's just it's obvious which which
direction this goes hopefully Elon comes
in some people are saying that with Elon
Musk potentially taking over Twitter in
a matter of days it will have an impact
on the midterms which brings me to this
next story I love it from the hill
Pelosi predicts Democrats will keep the
house after November's midterms she
actually said it was going to be a
landslide huh she said come on yeah she
said uh we will hold the house by
winning more seats Senate Roe v Wade is
going to result in the Democrats
actually winning hey man I think it's an
important story to talk about because
we're about a month away and uh hubris
will be your downfall considering Elon
Musk making this move has them so
worried maybe that's actually a sign
they're not going to win a month out
early voting is beginning to start
mail-in voting votes are ballots are
going out Elon let's say Elon takes over
and let's say this time next week Donald
Trump is back on the platform is that
good or bad will that help Democrats or
hurt them in the midterms
what do you guys think I think Elon Musk
taking over Twitter will help the
Republicans in the midterms but if
Donald Trump comes back I think that
hurts the Republicans I think if Trump
comes back on Twitter it's going to hurt
him yeah because the only thing
Democrats have to campaign on is hating
Donald Trump they tried to do it in uh
Virginia with Terry McAuliffe all of the
ads and Terry McAuliffe just kept
repeating Glenn yunkin is Trump
and that's like all he had it was just I
remember someone put together a
compilation video it was just Trump
trump it's all Terry McAuliffe would say
so yeah I think uh that that does hurt
overall
um not in all places the Republicans in
the way that it falls with the midterms
after uh taking the house and taking the
Senate it's statistically improbable
that they're going to keep the house
it's just the way history has shown it I
want to read this email that I got from
Nancy Pelosi because I was added to a
mailing list oh boy oh I emailed you yes
Nancy Pelosi emailed me and she titled
the email honestly oh
I told you my September 30th deadline
was the biggest of the year I told you
we failed to meet our goal for the first
time ever so today I'm asking you one
final time will you please chip in 15
before midnight to help me finally meet
my goal so that we have the resources to
close out strong and expand our way
historic majorities I thought she had a
so much confidence in that this was
going to be a land-sized victory they
were going to gain seats I'll be honest
oh we have two options oh boy
one either we let the Republicans win
capitalized the fundraising battle flood
capitalized our vulnerable Democrats
with expensive attacks and Barge their
way back into power or or
we step up we regain the fundraising
Edge and stop Republicans momentum in
its tracks isn't the Democratic party
funding a bunch of the Trump candidates
in some states yes they are because they
it's they're doing what Hillary Clinton
some of those places Hillary Clinton had
called Trump the Pied Piper it was a
Pied Piper candidate we're gonna amplify
him and you know it's it's we're going
to take him out so they're they're using
the same strategy because they don't
learn so uh they're they're amplifying
they're like yeah you know what this
works so well for Hillary let's do it in
all the states so they're amplifying the
Trump candidates and you know because
they're going to be easier to beat I
mean look the the 538 polling average
the real clear politics polling average
both have both predict the Republicans
to gain seats right according to the
most recent ones and
um I think Republicans typically
underperform on the polls so I think uh
it looks pretty great Carrie we're going
to have Carrie Lake in Arizona yeah
I love her she's up by like what two
points overall in the polls so I like to
see the states getting stronger let's
just do this Nancy let's pull up Nancy
Pelosi's favorability rating from Civics
with 203
175 responses
57 unfavorable okay I wanna I wanna ask
you guys about Joe Biden right wow this
is this is the the all all people pulled
right if I select only by democrats do
you think she will have a favorable or
unfavorable writing among Democrats
unfavorable I think
unfavorable nobody loves me unfavorable
but not in her District okay well I
can't search by that it's either
favorable or not unfavorable all right
and she's 75. why
they like her all right all right I
think it's that bikini photo oh God hold
on hold on Republican party that one's
this that's no-brainer right yeah it's
gonna be like 90
99. hey look at that there's three
percent of them
those are the the list Chinese no those
are the people who saw the bikini
picture yeah there you go yeah all right
here's the big here's the important one
though independent voters favorable or
unfavorable
unfavorable unfavorable unfavorable for
sure
wow oh my God am I having a stroke yeah
I mean but this this reminds me of the
recent National poll by the uh what it
was either the Washington Post or the
New York Times and whoever they
partnered with uh asking about
desantis's Bill with um Banning
sexualized curriculum they didn't
explicitly refer to his bill but they
said do you support or oppose having
sexualized curriculum in elementary
school and it was overwhelmingly opposed
overall like 70 to 80 percent among all
voters Nationwide and then among
Republicans it was like 96 opposed to
the that type of curriculum in
elementary schools Independence it was
like 80 90 opposed but Democrats it was
like even wow and it's like it's only
because they know that their party
supported this curriculum in the
classroom so they're just like kind of
hitching themselves too all right to
whatever the party now because because
the question Pelosi uh brings up is will
they win I gave you the next poll from
Civics Democratic party favorable rating
registered voters 430 31 735 responses
since 2015. among Democratic party
members do you think they will have the
Democrat they will view the Democratic
party favorably yeah of course they will
of course they will right
and they do 80 favorable uh they really
like Pelosi though Republicans obviously
don't like it with 96 unfavorable but
the big question is independent voters
what do you guys think this is
a good significance look at the
independency I think 64 unfavorable so
this is the point coming into the
midterms with the Democratic party and
Pelosi the leadership being despised
this much I gotta say it doesn't look
good for them and this idea they're
going to retain it doesn't seem to add
up in the polls however I'm going to go
back and I'm gonna pull up the
Republican party let me see if I can get
the Republican plan here because the
Republican party is always the funniest
one to me
everybody hates Mitch McConnell that's
hilarious that's there uh let's see
where's the Republican Party favorable
rating all right so the Republicans 59
unfavorable among Democrats kind of
obvious right yeah yeah everybody
Democrats just 95 yeah among independent
voters what do you guys I think it's
gonna be even you think it's gonna be
even slightly over slightly slightly
more favorable I think it's slightly
unfair 61 unfavorable Independence
despise their problems here's the best
part among those who are Republicans how
do they view the Republican party people
hate it oh God favorable no no no 73 is
good not as good as the Democrats yeah
not as good as Democrats in favor of
themselves but I do find it funny that
even among the Republican party they
generally like I remember seeing this
when it was like this is you know back
in 2017
32 percent unfavorable like Republicans
really just did not like the Republican
party and even now but I think the
funniest things when you go to like like
Mitch McConnell well you guys get the
point yep it's it's fairly obvious the
big question is where Independence gonna
go if they they hate the Republicans a
little bit less than the Democrats
I mean I think they go with at least
like I'm I'm mostly buried in the
education stuff The Independents are
going with the Republicans and then if
you just look at what people prefer as
far as what's important to them yes I
think The Independents are going with
the Democrats on the abortion issue but
that's not a top issue the top issue is
economy and the jobs and The
Independents go with the Republicans on
economy and the jobs and look inflation
is horrible right now uh uh just overall
economic outputs not doing really well
which does it help Biden and I think
it's going to help the Republicans there
are two types of Independents that I
know from living in Massachusetts one is
Bernie Sanders who's an independent and
another is the people who are they don't
want to say that they're Democrats
so they're Independents because they
don't like you know the Socialist aspect
or whatever and they see how that party
is going
um I guess there's three because then
there are the people who don't want to
say that they're Republicans you know
because they don't want the the stigma
attached to it you know um so yeah those
are those are kind of the three main I
mean most voters are Independents right
um or at least the plurality of them
um yeah so it's you know you see the way
The Independents are leaning then you're
like okay I can kind of gauge it you
know from there by who
how they kind of lean within their
independent I like the Mitch McConnell
poll because uh among Republicans 61
unfavorable yeah nobody likes him 17
favorable it's crazy because even Nancy
Pelosi has support from the Democratic
party I wonder what I wonder what 18 to
34 year old Republicans think yeah what
happened what was this the switch
um election time yeah election time yeah
did McConnell come out against Trump or
something at that time is there any
demographic that likes Mitch McConnell
how about the old people
old Republicans don't even like him okay
what about all Republican men no no wow
I mean non-college graduated old no no
all right nobody likes Mitch McConnell
that's it I wonder what the what his
favorability was when the whole cocaine
Mitch drama drops like the like the 18
to 24 year olds oh yeah look at this
it's cooler now among men Mitch
McConnell 80 unfavorable among an 83.
I'm like across the board everybody's
like among white people seven day
unfavorable black 93 Hispanic Latino 88
other 85 there's not a single
demographic that holds Mitch McConnell
favorably and he keeps winning I think
people just like yep let's just vote for
Mitch
have a huge Advantage yeah and
Kentucky's not really going to vote for
Democrats and he's always going to win
his his uh primary but hey at least it
shows you that the Republican party
isn't so much a cult as the Democrats
are less tribal yeah these people are
like no I don't like the leadership they
suck and the Democrats are like over
Pelosi yeah well they they stick
together they don't they don't diver at
all they're I mean and it's like if
there's even one thing that that they
draw separately on like take abortion
for instance you know like there was a
point where there was even Republicans
were sensitive to the fact that there
could be a 16 year old pregnant girl and
you know like we get that that's that's
terrible you know like she made mistakes
and whatever like there was a point
where that was a thing but then the
Democrats are like nope we're gonna
abort 40 week babies you know we're
gonna work after yeah the baby's born
yeah I mean they just took it and ran
and now it's to the point where it's
like there is no no no level ground at
all like you can't you can't be a
Democrat and say yeah well I I kind of
you know would oppose abortion in the
first trimester because it's like nope
you're you're a far right fascist that
actually happened on the show Sheamus is
sitting over here pro-life Catholic the
conservative Matt Bender's over here
Progressive pro-abortion I'm the
traditional you know Pro liberal
pro-choice like after the you know after
visibility again and then he's arguing
with me like I'm the pro-life guy and
I'm like dude I'm the pro-choice guy I'm
trying to help you out here yeah it's
like you're trying to make this you know
palatable again because it's not and
people don't want that and I mean it's
not even that people don't want that
it's statistically something like 80
percent of people support abortion in
the first trimester after into the
second trimester that number plummets to
27 will will support abortion and the
second trimester and third trimester is
like eight percent yeah but that's what
they're running on but have you
considered uh and uh you know Obama gets
this that there's too many kids gotta
blow them up yeah we gotta yeah there's
just too many I think today is also the
anniversary of Obama bombing uh a
charity organization oh the The Doctors
Without Borders Hospital yes oh I
remember when today's anniversary of
that yeah happy anniversary there was an
article why won't Obama stop killing
children
I was like he's the answer too many of
them yeah you know no the Democrats
don't have enough children
well the Democrats certainly look from
the leadership to the the Grassroots
they just think there's too many kids
there's too many policies literally
point to population control you look at
every policy that they push that they
promote every one of them just come out
and say it yeah and then the left are
like oh I'm not gonna have any kids
because of the climate it's like no you
want to extend your childhood that's why
you're not gonna have any kids you don't
care about the climate it's also a
responsibility
that's a weird thing too because I don't
understand that idea of like
you know you know what I noticed
there's
there's a lot of bands that I like I'll
just I'll keep it vague there's a lot of
art that I like and there are people
that are like 50 years old still working
and then I'm like why is it that it's
it's considered weird you know like a
band puts out you know some uh some new
music and they're like in their 50s and
their 60s and people are like wow
they're still making music and it's
because back in the day they weren't
still producing they were doing
consulting stuff they're making doing
some stuff but they had a family and
they're raising their family and they
were moving out their lives today
everybody's working and I was like why
is it that these people and then I
looked I'm like none of these people
have kids so like their whole lives are
just product and not family and so it's
a really interesting phenomenon to see
I don't know if like for these
Millennials uh and and just this current
generation or whatever
I don't understand you know I don't
think it's it's prolonging childhood
necessarily I I think it's it's it's
maybe just programming it's just you
know there was uh an article I saw
on The Daily Mail and it was like uh
Mother's uh post about how they regret
having kids and what what their lives
were like before kids there's another
post where it was like you know mothers
talk about their regret and what you
know how awful their children are and
I'm just like man they really don't want
you to have they really want to prop up
these narratives about having kids is
bad yep and you can just control
everybody else's kids through the
government school system so many of them
well in the UK they even had
advertisement being like do you want a
baby or do you want to play video games
as if video games were a good thing
which again a lot of people were finding
you know themselves addicted to and
again I think a lot of this is
multi-faceted I think there is an
element of it that is running away from
personal responsibility I think there's
also an element of it that is
pro-consumer pro multinational
corporation that understands that if
people don't have kids that they don't
uh have strong family units people will
of course use that energy towards
supporting them rather than themselves
and their family members and I think
deeper down there's also an elitist
level where it's like okay we need to
get rid of the people on this world
there's too many of them we need to do
population control we need to do
Eugenics but we're you know doing it in
many other handed ways that of course is
essentially at the end of the day uh
reducing the the number of people on
this world which already has hit a
critical level where we are going to be
dealing with the civilization crash very
soon all right question are there too
many people we need more we need more
yeah we need more because look in the
future we have all this national debt
we'll have it spread over more people so
it can pay it off in the future if you
have more people you could um have more
resources and that's what we really want
more resources so like so so the the
left's thinking of we have too many
people and we have to control population
is the fixed pie fallacy that there's a
finite amount of resources and you
divide it among this many people if you
have more people then that means fewer
resources for each individual person but
that assume assumes that people don't
create these resources themselves and so
I think we don't have enough people yeah
absolutely socialism too like you know
because they want you know more people
the more people in their their fixed
finite whatever like you're not you're
gonna get one bar of soap you that you
get to choose from you know they they
drop stuff like that so that's coming
from kind of their communist or their
socialist you know perspective and then
if you look at uh getting rid of the
family that's that's a tenet of Marxism
like a lot of a lot of these go back to
Marxism it's everywhere and it's not
just Financial ramifications of less
people being around but statistically
the population is increasing but is
expected to go down dramatically if you
look at the Western World people aren't
reproducing enough this is not only
going to lead to a financial crisis but
this is going to lead to a very serious
one which Elon Musk has even compared to
the potential potentially the greatest
risk to humanity is people not
reproducing enough and if you look at
you look at also what's happening behind
the scenes with levels sperm levels all
of them dramatically going down there's
a big probability that that human beings
could become infertile very soon with
the the rates of of just estrogen with
the rates of chemical warfare that is
happening that no one really wants to
talk about which is absolutely absurd
well certainly resources are not
infinite and more people doesn't mean
more resources it means less like
there's a finite amount of rare earth
minerals that we can extract from the
planet it may be such a great number
we're nowhere near reaching that cap but
the planet is finite in terms of what
its mass is and what we can extract not
to mention that there's a certain amount
of uh I mean we we can overfish we can
we've we've made animals go extinct
before at a certain point I think that
the question is is wrongly framed when
it's are there too many people it's are
we managing the system properly I think
the answer is no I think it's not being
managed properly and the response from
people like Bill Gates is instead of
trying to figure that out just less
people because then you don't got to
worry about it I think I'm thinking
about
aoc's District uh or Nancy Pelosi's
District 770 some odd thousand people
how do you effectively govern that many
people you can't so the issue isn't
necessarily one of proper allocation of
resources it may be can you effectively
manage this many people like like
together can they work together in such
a way
I I would say right now the systems we
put in place a couple hundred years ago
can't account for this because they were
expecting I think like 35 000 people per
per member of Congress and now we have
nearly a million I mean three quarters
of a million but that that just means we
need to figure out a better way of
managing expectations and and you know
working within the representative system
well you know there's ways of having a
sustainable system there's ways of
individuals being responsible for
themselves having their own Farms
producing their own food there's enough
to go around it nature is an abundant
beautiful landscape that is ready just
to grow food out of the ground and and
what we're seeing from the the central
controllers from the Bill Gates's from
the Klaus Schwabs is move into a city go
eat the bugs and and live in a pot and
again that's not the answer here the
real answer here is people finding
themselves in nature and becoming
dependent on themselves and not
responsible and and not dependent on the
federal government and this is what
another reason why I don't trust any of
their narratives on climate change
overpopulation because they they keep
they they have that video the line the
city where they're gonna put everybody
in a super condensed space and I'm like
population density is supposedly the
problem the pollution the waste but
they're not I don't think they actually
care about climate change I don't think
they actually care about our population
they care about creating a reason to
scare you into living under their
control
Elon Musk is right we need more people I
was watching Star Trek you guys see the
remember the new Star Trek with what's
his name Chris Pine is that his name and
there's that scene where he rides up on
the motorcycle and he sees the gigantic
Starship and I'm just thinking how many
people do you need to build something
like that it's massive we're trying to
build a building right now and it's like
a 7 500 square foot building and it's
taken like a year to get done because of
supply chain crunch imagine trying to
build this massive Starship that has
faster than light travel and can hold
thousands of people or whatever and I
was like you don't just need more people
you need more specialists so that means
with all the people we have Elon my
point is Elon Musk is right the more
people you have the more Specialties you
can have like some dude can be a
chocolatier I was reading about some guy
I wanted to talk and I'm just like it's
kind of a crazy thing oh no it was the
uh the Bros movie when it was like the
guy wanted to be a chocolatier whatever
was part of the movie in the review and
uh I'm like what a job you know like go
back several hundred years and it's like
you're you're in the middle of the
Wilderness with a hatchet and you're
like I'm gonna stop hunting and go make
chocolate it's not gonna happen no but
as population grows everybody can assume
a very specific job and Specialty so the
more people we have the more
capabilities technologically we have but
I think Bill Gates knows this I think
these powerful Elites know this so their
attitude is we don't necessarily want to
get rid of people we want to get rid of
certain people and have everybody else
live in the cities eat the bugs and do
what we want them to do so we can have
nice things well I think what you hit on
earlier is important too though that it
depends on the system that we operate in
and so if we have more personal
responsibility more of a free market
competition and trade than uh the thing
that I was pointing out earlier that you
can get stuck in a fixed pie Pi fallacy
if you don't have those incentives in
place but if you if you do have a free
market and there is competition there's
capitalism you can have an incentive to
produce more even though there is more
people on the planet you have more
resource sources for per person as
opposed to that and I think it's more
than I just want to have nice things or
I want to have it all I think there's a
deeper religious uh spiritual aspect to
this that I think you know it may be not
worth talking about now but there's a
lot of circumstantial evidence
highlighting how you know human
progression has been created with of
course abundant energy and we see a lot
of central controllers deny energy to
populations which of course denies the
progression of humanity progression of
human beings progression of innovation
and technology that of course creates
life a better life that that is more
resilient that is that is more amazing
that is more incredible they're denying
that what if moloch is real and he wants
the blood of children and you know hey
look you know for all we know Bill Gates
is you know he's down in the Deep
dungeon and there's a there's a big door
with big chains across it needs a lot
and there's a bunch of guys holding the
doors like hold them back I'll bring the
children in brings in a bunch of kids
they used to sacrifice you know children
in ancient civilizations and this is a
practice that of course probably didn't
go away from my own personal opinion and
perspective uh just the way I see the
way Society plays out right now you see
everything going towards one trajectory
and that is destruction of humanity
destruction of the human Spirit and the
will of humanity to progress Build and
Grow you see the government standing in
the way you see the multinational
corporation standing in the way you see
the bankers you see the central
controllers and billionaires standing in
the way of the biggest amazing human
potential that we could unleash on the
world and they're literally trying to
control our thoughts through social
media which is and and limit those
thoughts and limit our energy and limit
our ability to do so which is
infuriating because there's so much
wonders about our existence there's so
many questions there's so much science
there's so much intelligence but all of
that is just being
pooped on by all right
child hurting nasty human beings that
that don't don't like the human spirit
and stand against it so there's a
Japanese term it's called ekage and icky
means life and gay means worth and
essentially that's the intersection of
what you're good at uh what you love to
do what gives you what what gives you
purpose and we're at a point where we're
just we're privileged you know I hate
using that word because they've
repurposed it but the fact that we can
we can be chocolatiers yeah you know
like we can we can we can be YouTubers
we can we can be whatever we want to be
um you know and and and the people that
love what they do or the people that add
goodness and Joy to the World and like
we're blessed to be living in a place
where we don't have to you know hack up
trees and you know like grunt to
communicate with each other
um you know so we're in a good place
we're we're in a good place for ikigay
and we gotta we gotta kind of figure out
how to hold that you know on a side note
too I was just thinking when we were
talking about all the people preventing
ikigay essentially
um the banks there was there was one
Banker CEO of somewhere and he was
questioned by Congress on ESG and he was
like absolutely not and it was Rashida
Talib who asked the question and she
didn't even know what yes and she didn't
even know what to do she was just like
oh and she was like all you know
flabbergasted and she was like oh okay
well I guess that you just want climate
change I don't even know like she said
something totally irrational like in
reactionary to him but yeah I was like
okay well you know what this is good
because ESG is to the economy what CRT
is to schools like this is this is bad
so Tim you you had asked about the
population too much for too little the
the temperature on Earth is it too high
or too low
I neither we don't we don't know what
the best answer is right I mean I don't
yeah I mean nobody knows just depends on
what your preference is I guess the
world goes through normal uh undulation
when it comes to hot and cold
temperatures it goes up it goes down it
goes up it goes down and we got to jump
to this next door here
from The Daily Mail
germaphobe Howard Stern leaves his
apocalypse bunker for the first time in
two years for A-list dinner with
Jennifer Aniston Jimmy Kimmel and Jon
Hamm and admits he's been afraid of
catching coven how many times that's
just it that's just a wow moment his
immune system has just got to be shot he
hasn't seen a germ in two years yeah
he's gonna get real sickness he's going
to get really really sick it's not gonna
be coveted either whatever it's gonna be
exactly he's completely he's gonna get
everything yeah it's gonna be like like
Mr Burns you Remember The Simpsons and
the germs through the door he probably
bought a whole jug of like uh
antiseptic alcohol sanitizer which again
that kills your immune system too kills
your immune system and kills the good
bacteria as well as the bad bacteria and
you need you know a combination of good
bacteria doesn't have a healthy gut the
radio host admitted on Monday the outing
was emotionally exhausting and it was
the first time in two years I ventured
out of the house who still listens to
this guy you are listening to someone
who is not well dude needs deep deep
therapy he's saying it was emotionally
exhausting for the first time in two
years bro isolated himself for two years
do not take advice from this man I don't
know I don't know who is it's still
following this guy's politics this guy
is out of his mind yeah and but he is in
a 20 million dollar home so it couldn't
have been too bad
I'm sure I know I'm sure I'm sure he's
got a a pinball machine a hot tub he's
got an infinity pool and all that great
stuff that's not the point the point is
the dude is agoraphobic like this is not
the kind of person that you should be
listening to consistently
does anybody listen to this guy
consistently yeah he's got like tens of
millions of listeners on on Sirius or
whatever he's still on he imprisoned
himself in his own mind which is
absolutely terrifying because he was a
perfect byproduct of what the corporate
media wanted the average citizen to be
and as we were talking you know you need
good bacteria and bad bacteria but but
when you when you lack good bacteria in
your gut this is correlated with a lot
of people having very negative mental
health so I think there's a correlation
with him being overly protective using
too much hand sanitizers using too much
stuff not going outside not being in
nature not feeling the dirt not getting
any sun not getting any vitamin D that
correlated with his mental decline that
has led to a situation where he
literally imprisons himself and doesn't
go outside for two years check it check
us out he said quote I said to my wife I
don't want to go I'm in a panic I don't
want to get covered yeah anxiety if you
want to leave now yeah it's agoraphobia
it's not germophobia it's agoraphobia
maybe it was a trump derangement
syndrome may have Trump would have said
yeah you guys should all stay in your
house he would have freaked out and he
would have been partying every night
that's a good man that's crazy
Stern however was reportedly maskless
the dinner party according to a diner
who had snapped the photo how he was
there without even a mask on the outside
the large table Stern told the
restaurant staff it was his first night
out since the start of the pandemic yo
that's the way
that's three years was he really that
scared if he's not wearing a mask and
it's his first time out or was he well
he probably realizes you know like hey
this doesn't work either
this is pointless after looking at the
data after after being so long but it's
going somewhere to eat too like yeah
yeah I mean we know we know the rules of
restaurants right like you take the mask
off and you when you're sitting down
you know it would be really ironic is
that if he gets coveted now and then
he's like I got it I went out I gotta go
back in for two more I mean he's got to
be shots boosters he's got to have it
all yes which again a lot of data is
coming out highlighting some interesting
findings
highlight that he probably will be
getting sick especially if he well just
yeah whatever he's gonna get something
absolutely you can't lock yourself up
for two years whether it's the flu yep
whether it's whether it's the cold
whatever it is it's gonna hit him it's
going to hit him hard that's why
periodically I go outside and eat stake
right off the ground just to make sure
my immune system is strong and ready to
go
that's one way of doing it just just
make sure no animal poops in there but
yeah grounding being in the sun being in
nature uh you know just being exposed to
to other germs and bacteria gives you a
good immune system this is why a lot of
people
some people actually have supplements
and the supplements are from dirt
there's actually medications from dirt
that are also very controversial that we
can all talk about hold on no you're
supposed to eat dirt but let me let me
clarify we used to get a lot of
nutrients because we would pull the
vegetables out of the ground or off
branches and they have like not like
thick dirt you're eating dirt but
there's like dust and dirt still on the
plant and you do you eat it we started
cleaning all that stuff off and I was
reading about how that lowered the
amount of B vitamins we were getting not
just that but because of mono cropping
because of simply just growing corn and
soy and allowing Monsanto to control the
entire agricultural industry along with
other big corporate Giants we have
destroyed nutrition from our vegetables
and fruits a lot of the fruits a lot of
the vegetables don't contain the same
amount of macronutrients as they
previously did before decades ago and
therefore our food is slowly and surely
being wilted away to absolutely be mush
that is meaningless without any kind of
sustenance for you as a human being so
do I have to buy 10 tomatoes and eat
them instead of five well yeah yeah do I
eat double the the salad now or what do
I do well you've got to be careful with
the glycopate inside of there I want to
uh Stonewall Jackson's Shenandoah
compound because it's in um it's in
Winchester I think it was like use it
for a few months while he was playing
the defense of the Shenandoah during the
Civil War and in the kitchen they had a
a a musket from like 1820 up on the wall
and they said what they would do is when
they're making dinner they would have
the door open and if they saw a critter
outside I'd grab the musket and just
shoot it and then take it and throw it
in the stew like fresh just like that
it's kind of a crazy thought eating
squirrel groundhog rabbit or Badger or
whatever they happen to see but also the
crazy thought of something so fresh
taken right from the yard Bang there you
go here's dinner that's right from the
other crazy thing was they had a win
they called winter Pantry right above
the kitchen they just took meat and hung
it up they didn't refrigerate it or
anything you know so I we I was I was at
a steakhouse and they had the the dry
aging steaks just sitting out and it was
like gotta be it's like sits out for a
month it's kind of crazy thought people
would just throw the meat in a room and
hang it back there you go put some salt
on it and kind of store it that way I
don't think they even did that yeah I
think when they were transporting and
stuff they would they would smoke it and
then just leave it up there I guess
yeah I mean my family still does that in
Poland every time I go to Poland they're
like oh yeah you know we're just smoking
the meat just having a bunch of jokes
there
so I guess he had people
um just delivering Uber Eats and stuff
to his house or family or I don't know
if he had Uber Eats coming in or or yeah
I guess they can drop it on the doorstep
or something
he has like what are those rooms called
where it's like one door opens and then
you put the food and then it closes the
contamination room yeah like it sprays
it then he opens it up and takes it out
I wouldn't be surprised if that's
exactly
get Lysol it everywhere he's wealthy
enough he'd probably want to do uh I
wouldn't be surprised if you got like
special order Farm food that was
harvested by like his select people oh
because the thing about fast food is
like you don't know what they're doing
when they prepare it I remember that
viral video where a dude was at Taco
Bell I think it was Taco Bell and he
stood in the lattice or something like
that do you guys remember that oh yeah
maybe it was Burger King or something
yeah yeah he was like standing in it
there's a bunch of videos where people
do that where they're like screwing with
the food and then they were posting it
online you never know man for all we
know you know Howard Stern orders uh
what's that ghost grocery delivery
service you can order I don't know
whatever instacart is that it is he
orders ice cream and he gets the one ice
cream that girl licked and put back so
he thinks you think you're safe Howard
Stern they're getting the germs in your
food when you order it I mean did he
keep his Maids I mean I assume he's got
a 20 million dollar mansion He had made
yeah you guys must stay yeah he probably
was like we're all in her house arrest
now
it worked for me you got to stay
here
no leaving yeah what happened to people
like this dude used to be an edgelord
and now he's just like a terrified panic
attack agoraphobe I mean really just
think about it though if everybody did
what he did
you want to have people producing
anything you want to have food I mean I
guess unless he started I'm not worried
about my own thing in his yard but we
got we got a bunch of Critters and deer
all over the place and I'm not gonna
pretend like you know we we would be
able to survive off the land or anything
like that but I'm confident that um
after some hardship if everything were
to collapse we'd be all right out here
we'd figure it out and we would we would
find a way people in cities and people
like him they would just melt they would
be sitting it would just like slowly
become one with his chair and just like
it stuck to it and be like and then
within a couple weeks he'd be gone he
also became very angry he uh criticized
very heavily Joe Rogan Aaron Rodgers he
even uh Howard Stern specifically said
that if if you're unvaccinated you
should be denied treatment out of out of
hospitals hospitals should be quote
closed to individuals who are not
vaccinated so this is a man who wants to
see other people suffer who wants to see
other people die as of course he's taken
for granted his lifestyle that of course
the average poor person can afford the
an average person can't hide in a 20
million dollar mansion and not be able
to to work or or do hard labor or blue
collar work so for him to go out and say
this uh on on the heels of his paranoia
is just mind-boggling I remember you had
people advocating on the news on CNN uh
doctors advocating for
um not allowing you to fly state to
state because that's a federal issue now
uh unless you're vaccinated I was like
oh [ __ ] but we're all doing this
together we're all in this together but
if you have a private jet not a big deal
you can you can still go wherever you
want yeah it's time to jump to the most
important story of the night ladies and
gentlemen I have a very important
announcement to make this is breaking
news huge developing story
Scooby-Doo's Velma Dinkley finally
confirmed as lesbian in new trick or
treat film as new female love interest
is introduced that's it I know all of
your Velma fantasies are over everybody
weird Velma fetishes they're done she is
officially a lady lover they have
confirmed it well there goes my chances
in Velma with a non-existent cartoon
character dang it so I just I I don't
know I saw the story I thought it was
funny because Mike why
that just no serious why
does Velma need to be attracted someone
for her character to work because like
is there a reason why after what it's
been like 50 years because they lean too
heavily on gender and sexuality and
explosions now and they don't have good
storylines anymore so they're gonna pull
in a whole different demographic of
people to watch it who are like oh I
feel seen it's my representation
representation is important I mean real
quick real quick for those big
Scooby-Doo fans has sexuality been a
component of the show at all never
is Fred going like hey baby and you know
something like that I mean when they did
the live action Scooby-Doo with uh uh I
don't even remember Prince Junior
Freddie Prince yeah and
um um Sarah Michelle Geller uh Matthew
Lillard and I don't know play who played
on that yeah yeah but like I think the
larger question is was there any was
there any tension in that like Johnny
Bravo Mama I think so that would be the
clothes there were like gags and stuff
but I I the reason I bring this up this
question is because Scooby-Doo is for
kids why is Velma like I I've not I mean
oh you know what no there was Scooby had
a girlfriend didn't he in like one of
the movies did he but there's like not a
big sexual component of Scooby-Doo to
begin with so this is just out of place
period for the show like you don't you
don't see it like in the cartoon it's
like
almost every single episode of the show
ever is that some dude is trying to
lower property value by pretending to be
a ghost or a mummy or something yeah and
then they're like he was trying to scam
people it just shows you that the
monsters are adults and the monsters are
you know scammers yeah
but I guess would have gotten away
that's the lesson but now it's monsters
are people the whole time and film is
gay yeah that's it well because you need
accurate representation
the producers of Scooby-Doo is it you
know Harvey Weinstein
why are they interjecting sexual
preference in a kids movie I think
everyone should be asking themselves
well Disney also does a lot of sinister
subliminal messages and and and puts
wieners everywhere so they have a
horrible track record especially with a
lot of their younger stars but um as Tim
pulled up here there's there's well I
think I think we need to point out that
shaggy is trans it's been been that way
way well so right I I've I've seen if my
fair share of Scooby-Doo I mean it's
been around it's older than I am and I'm
like Shaggy's been dressing like like a
lady for a while like it's a common
Trope in the Scooby-Doo series and so I
gotta wonder if these doctors are saying
that kids who play with dolls or want to
dress like girls are trans maybe
Shaggy's trying to tell us something or
the producer trying to tell something
about Shaggy
I was looking back at this and I was
like oh there's cross-dressing in every
kid's movie why is this like because it
was a joke seriously yeah
like in The Lion King you have to Timon
who's like what do you want me to do
dress and drag and do the hula and the
next scene he's in drag doing the hula
yep you know and it's it's comical
because it's like oh well that's funny
but now it's like that's not funny yeah
it can't be fun I can't be funny anymore
Linda Cardellini played Velma in the
live action see I don't know who that is
because I can tell you like Freddie
Prince Junior Matthew Lillard and Sarah
Michelle Geller are famous enough to him
like I remember who they were but like I
have no idea who this lady is did she
like did she do other stuff after this
because I don't know she was a lesbian
honestly Velma yeah look at her yeah we
have one look at this guy we have one
velma's a lesbian with impeccable taste
congratulations you won that was yours
uh Velma also uh calls the police on
people in that video game
multiverses and it caused a huge outrage
because they were like it's racist to
call the cops I guess and people were
posting videos this is a fighting game
you guys hear about multiverses and you
can play as like Warner Brothers
characters so like Batman Shaggy Velma
is a character and so is LeBron and
velma's special ability was to call the
police and then a police car arrests you
and then drives off the edge
yeah exactly they were calling her a
Karen saying yeah she was like you're in
big trouble now and the squad car grabs
the person and like people are posting
videos of LeBron getting arrested and
then people were even leftists were
tweeting like yo is this like kind of
weird that velma's arresting this black
guy and then the squad car drives off
the cliff and then he dies that's how
the game works
yeah
so you won that allows me but she's also
a Karen I lost because my chances with
Velma I'm forever gone I never get to
dream about it well it's always kind of
been a dynamic between
um lgbtq and uh you know black lives
matter like especially in June you know
and then when they have like their month
and then every like every time the uh
LGBT or black lives matter would get
something it would always be like they'd
have to share it and I remember this
being like a big controversy between the
two different factions that so there is
always something between the two I don't
know if they're trying to pit it against
each other or what it is but they also
tried saying that Samus from Metroid was
a trans trans woman salmon so uh yeah
yeah Samus so uh you guys know the game
Metroid it's uh originally it's like it
was nes and you're a person wearing this
the suit and you you know shoot from
your hand or whatever and then do flips
and at the end if you get the good
ending it reveals that the character
Samus was a woman whole time and like
Nintendo she takes the helmet off and
there's blonde hair and was like ah
reveal and so then throughout the years
you know the character has been
developed and metroid's got a ton of
games and Sam Samus in the Metroid suit
or whatever it's called is in Smash
Brothers and they were saying like this
proves that Samus is actually a trans
woman the whole time they're trying to
change the character the problem was
there's like a bunch of Art and Samus
zero suit Samus is the character in
Smash Brothers and it's like that's a
chick it's like it's overtly a woman
with you know big tits and and a butt so
instead of being like um oh look at what
women can achieve you know it's like no
it was a man the whole time who you know
is a woman is actually a male oh yeah
man of the year oh yeah a trans woman
yeah so I beat you in all the sports too
this is the thing you know like one of
the tweets here was uh what is this is
this James Gunn someone said please make
our live-action lesbian Velma dreams
come true says I tried in 2001. all
right tried and 2001 Velma was
explicitly gay in my initial script
studio just kept watering it down and
watering it down becoming ambiguous the
version then nothing and finally having
a boyfriend in the sequel oh so actually
velma's bi like canonically if in the
movie she had a boyfriend and she likes
girls she's not a lesbian so guys you
you are incorrect but um someone said
Velma being gay is actually massive
we're at a point in time when this major
character full of decades-old history
and fans gets to actually be a lesbian
and that's just another part of her
Cannon now sometimes we need to
celebrate these wins I just don't
understand why it's like don't you want
your own characters
so we were talking about the other the
other night that they can't make people
famous anymore this is like the ability
to make celebrities is weakening and
like the ability to create content and
characters has failed nobody wants to
make it make a uh well here's a
character armadillo guy like Batman it's
like Batman over and over and over again
every movie Spider-man Batman Spider-man
that's all they ever do make armadillo
man someone's probably already done it
okay how about how what's an obscure
animal ostrich dude yeah and um you know
he's a guy who does like an ostrich
there you go yeah Stan Lee had actually
come out and said that you know the like
the way he wrote his characters he wrote
them specifically like he wrote people
like you know and he was attached to
people you know so you get like
Mary Jane for instance a redhead let's
go into redhead Erasure you know that's
something I hear a lot about but um you
know like but but they just reimagined
the characters as being different than
who who they were created to be at their
Foundation well I'm I'm really upset
about The Little Mermaid because they
put an actress in ginger face yes that's
right
that's very disrespectful to the Irish
people it is that we highly respect here
on the show of course uh but also more
importantly uh
more importantly I I wish characters in
in entertainment actually have
personalities actually had interesting
story lines instead of just like hey
this is my sexual preference because
we're seeing that more and more and more
and it's like okay who are you as a real
person who are you when when it comes to
reduce people to their sexuality or
their race and it's damn do you guys
think this is going to reduce
profitability of these shows because
people I mean like Netflix right they
got in woke they're going broke right
um oh they're bleeding subscribers and I
bet it's because a lot of people are
jumping [ __ ] yeah people don't want to
either way even if they support the
movements it's like I just want I don't
want it to be political at all or it's
not that I think we we do want to a
certain degree some Politics on our
content but subtle and
um what's the right word balanced there
was a video a viral video from some show
Boston Legal maybe it was and it was
um it might have been James Spader and
William Shatner I could be wrong and
their their friends William Shatner's I
think it I could be wrong but I think
Shatner is like the the mentor to this
younger guy who's a liberal and he's a
Republican and then they make a joke
about each other being Republican and
liberal and then smile and look off into
the sunset or whatever like that's the
kind of politics where we're like oh
yeah you know like express your idea
challenge the idea and then have a
nuanced conversation we don't get that
now it's just like are you a bigot you
know that's just it it's just overt over
the top one dimensional
for what reason is Velma is Velma
sexuality a component of the show it
doesn't need to be but
because they reduce people to their
sexuality now I mean look I get it you
are but they've done Scooby having a
girlfriend or whatever and then like
Shaggy had a girlfriend but it turned
out she was an alien I guess yeah I
can't remember what movie that was but
there's been there's so much Scooby-Doo
stuff but like it ends with him being
like zoing she was like an alien the
whole time like so is the dog the dog
so like no they've done weird stuff but
my point is just like
as we as we say it all the time
shouldn't you just make a new character
shouldn't you just write news stories
and then the other the other issue is
why would I want like if if you know if
you were if if you're gonna have your
kids watch something why would you want
them to watch
this kind of stuff so I don't think that
this is any longer a child's show I
think and I will say I'm gonna have the
controversial take after giving it some
thought I think it's fine that they have
a lesbian representation in the show
because I don't know if you guys are
familiar with the lesbian bar scene
probably not I don't know why I am for
sure there's like two left in the entire
country lesbians don't count anymore if
you'll recall lesbians were last being
called transphobic for not wanting to
engage in certain acts right they're
turfs because they're just lesbians they
like other women like biological women
but the features of biological women and
I think that this is actually a positive
thing because I don't I don't think that
Scooby-Doo is a children's show anymore
I think it's a relic of an older
generation so this is like them Reviving
Hocus Pocus right yeah it's for older
people it's not really for kids and I
think lesbian representation is good
I talked about this I was talking about
that Meme with Abe Simpson where he's
like you know I used to be with it but
then they changed what it was and now
what it is it's scary and it'll happen
to you too and I was like that's not
gonna happen to us it's not going to
happen to us because people aren't
having kids that means gen Alpha is
going to be smaller and that means gen
double Elf or whatever comes next is
going to be even smaller
listen listen so what's going to happen
is we're all going to be 50 or 60 or
whatever and and we're all going to be
working and producing still and
Millennials aren't going to have kids
and then you're gonna get a big promoter
who says we want to do a show a rock
concert and we want to make the most
money and they're going to say oh yeah
the generation beta artist he can
attract about 20 million people but the
millennial artist is going to bring in
75 why there are more Millennials yeah
it is yep it's just it it's it's a
market-sized thing it used to be that
the new generation was always slightly
bigger than the last so it was always
more profitable to Target the Next
Generation because it's a bigger market
share when they move in the key demo but
now you're gonna have 18 to 35 year olds
there's going to be 20 million of them
and there's going to be 7 million
Millennials or whatever and they're
going to be like what's the point the
market share is microscopic don't pan to
these people and they're going to have
to live in the shadow of the millennial
and gen Z's generation that's positive
because then they're going to have to
create their own culture they're gonna
have to make their own art they're gonna
have to develop their own music Styles I
think it's this is where we break from
corporatism so I'm feeling very
optimistic about this I mean we'll see
if I'm correct like we'll have to wait
for a few years but I think you're right
because it is never gonna change because
now I think gen Z is the largest
demographic right now I was reading
something about that yesterday and then
I think after that it's gonna super
taper off
um because uh gen Z is the product of
genetics right mostly Gen X yeah yeah
and then uh I don't think I think the
oldest Millennial they're not what's the
youngest gen Z
I'll say like 12 15. okay so the
Millennials could have gen Z kids if
like the oldest Millennials but it's
mostly like a Gen X thing I think my
kids are gen Z yeah I think so yeah
there you go yeah so Jen Alpha is going
to be tiny yeah
yeah we'll see maybe gen Z has like a
revolt against you know Millennials and
gen x's and they're like you're lame
we're gonna have 50 kids and go to
church that seems to be what happens I
mean if you look at like even the 80s
like uh you know they were the product
of the hippies and they all went and
became Republicans you know like it was
it was their way to lash out against
their hippie parents that's awesome all
right we're gonna go to super chats if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash the like button subscribe to this
Channel and share the show with your
friends head over to timcast.com become
a member we're gonna have that members
only uncensored show coming up tonight
at 11 PM you don't want to miss it so
smash that like button let's read these
super chats Matthew Hammond says I love
Figaro I told you thank you Matthew he's
beautiful he is beautiful he is he was
voted the hottest libertarian cat on
Twitter let's go
chippy's Channel says today today's
corporations are anti-free market today
blizzard has started denying people's
service based on what phone company they
use look into this it only gets worse
the more you read crazy
all right SK says Tim and crew I finally
got my Canadian passport anyway y'all
hiring I can do things like laugh really
loud and make fun of Ian also Josie has
the most lit Twitter account ever big
fan oh thank you I don't think we can
hire Canadians it's got all the
qualifications we can't hire Canadians
we've got to be you got to be American
you got to be a citizen Next Step
Josh Butler says Elon pretend not
wanting to buy to catch people
red-handed um
interesting oh yeah yeah but but they
were trying to get him to buy so of
course they were preparing he only
bought him more time people are also
losing thousands of followers everywhere
on on Twitter right now it's crazy yeah
I'm down like three to five thousand
yeah same yeah
Leif Hagin says everyone say Hey Siri
remind me at at 8 pm Eastern every
weekday at timcast irlazon take that
YouTube
oh yeah is that that works for iPhones
right what's the Android one you'd say
Okay Google remind me at 8pm Monday
through Friday that Tim cast IRL is on
something like that yeah probably would
be better if I said 7 45 p.m yeah
I wonder how many people's phones are
going off and they're just like uh
notifications went through that's funny
Darren Daly says I formally nominated
Kamala Harris for the Nobel Peace Prize
amazing just 10 minutes at the DMZ in
Kamala forged a Peace Tree with North
Korea and formed an alliance to battle
Putin here wonderful nailed it based
Kamala yeah oh snap it's Dave says
bigger food shortages coming for
restaurants Cisco one of if not the
biggest food distributors in central New
York that delivers all over Northeast is
on strike doesn't look good for New York
Governor
Cisco's everything yeah wow people don't
understand that every Diner you go to
you're probably eating Cisco so were
they so are they based in New England or
are they all over the country or are
they they distribute all over all over
the country so they're New England bait
because he said about New England
somewhere why are they on strike don't
know yeah I don't know but have you ever
noticed that when you go to diners the
pancakes are always the same it's
probably because it's just Cisco oh yeah
I knew somebody who worked for a bakery
and they sourced their own ingredients
and apparently Cisco went to them this
is what I was told uh they went to them
and said we'll give you five months free
supplies whatever you need for your shop
for free but to do a contract with us
for x amount of years wow and that would
that would have meant like tens of
thousands of dollars for free wow and
they were like no dice because then
you're just selling every the same thing
everybody else is selling yeah it's
crazy man
Damian Carpenter says man six minutes
late because YouTube never notified me I
love all you guys and you should try
getting YouTube wendigoon on the show
does icebergs and deep dives into video
games horror stuff and some history very
cool maybe a pop culture crisis thing
maybe uh yeah
openspatches.com says Jim cast his best
cast well shim sham Sheamus left us he's
gone
Sheamus who
James James uh James Coughlin yes
my favorite episode was when he had the
Roe v Wade cake that was so good yeah
that was that made my that made my heart
smile Planned Parenthood was advertising
ex-runner says
Elon troll the Twitter employees it's
been about 160 days that's more than
enough for a Xanax prescription to wear
off
what do we got
child of Ash says Elon is going to add
the Doge to Twitter when he does he gets
double the money no I mean look you
think it's a joke but Elon seriously if
he says we're going to implement Doge as
a tipping mechanism and then his doge
Holdings Skyrocket
he's not stupid he's probably like I'm
gonna double my money or to buy Twitter
premium which he talked about getting
rid of advertisers and making it a
subscription model for certain users for
certain features that yeah probably is
going to happen through Georgia it's
going to be 2042 and everything's gonna
be Dogecoin you're going to be like
going to the store and you're gonna be
like uh I'm I'll you go to McDonald's
you're like I'll get the number seven
that's 73 Dosh and like oh can you scan
your phone and it gives the difference
and then when you scan Elon musk's face
pops up on your phone he's like thanks
for buying yeah
get the brain chip yep yep everyone's
got the brain chip you're you're like
you're going on Facebook and it's like
to continue viewing please please
deposit 50 Dosh okay deposit
Shane Kina says Trump Trump's basically
playing hard to get with Twitter say he
won't come back be what everyone wants
but can I get but he will eventually
long term likely I think so too he has
to come back yeah it's it's you know he
instantly gains access to 80 million new
followers he's only got like three or
four million on true social he'll
probably have a lot more than he had
before yeah before the band now that
he's been banned so long plus people are
seeing how bad it was under Joe Biden
they're gonna be like I'm gonna follow
this guy and see what's going on yeah
an orange sea lion says Elon with one
heck of an October surprise oh yeah
which reminds me I'm really excited this
one's gonna be amazing oh yeah before
the midterms lots of surprises one of
the surprises that like Joe Biden craps
his pants and then they have to like
switch him out and they're making direct
eye contact with the people of America
[Laughter]
they even The Daily Beast is running
articles right now saying you can't
ignore Joe Biden's broken brain when he
called out that dead congresswoman even
left his Publications and liberal
Publications were like this is bad so
Joe Biden crapping his pants on TV like
this or next week gives them an
opportunity to swap out someone stronger
like just bring someone and be like here
you go and that person gives the last
couple of weeks of campaigning a big
boost when he just recently confirmed
Joe Biden that he's running again in
2024 like it was pretty much Biden said
that yeah a couple of days yesterday
maybe
um I don't remember which Outlet
reported it but
cheese but he finally said yeah he's
gonna do it yeah jota boy says if you
think musk is truly pro-free speech
wouldn't censor his dissenters and is
doing this for any reason other than to
build his own AI I'd like to talk to you
about a bridge I have for sale really
Chota what's the which Bridge yeah I'm
definitely interested I like bridges
yeah yeah uh no I I agree actually to a
certain extent the access to Twitter is
an amazing data stream for building an
AI yeah just like the raw Insanity of
humanity just spilling out like crazy
just like a stream and he could take it
and then he's gonna use it to build a
robot Mega human
it's gonna be like that robot he built
Optimus it's just gonna come out one day
and be like I am the culmination of all
humans and then it's gonna just like
start looking at pictures of cats
yep that's what humans do and then he's
like no stop you have to do something
more than this and it's like humans just
want to look at cats too that's true
internet's four yeah but that's one
thing they don't consider if we base our
AI off humans when like the Terminators
come and they're like marching and
they're like all you gotta do is grab a
cat and hold it and it goes disarming
like cannot hurt cat because like people
hate each other you know we're fighting
all day on Twitter
but not the cats man somebody messes
with cats or dogs on the internet
everyone's like no
people love cats man they actually like
dogs more but cats are the meme so yeah
the Toxoplasma is strong
cats would ever work for the police
right exactly it would never knock you
Daniel nemes says I had 200 people
following me on Twitter and today all of
a sudden I have three
hundred people and now as of today I
have 1700 so obvious it's obvious you
had only bots on your Twitter account
I'm sorry Eric Redbeard says when the
world economic Forum says stakeholder
they do not mean you stakeholders to
them are noteworthy decision makers not
us Pros themselves oh is this good for
me so not the regular people not the hoi
polloi yep
attack Fuji says Tim been following you
in Luke since occupy why haven't you had
Adam Curry on No Agenda has been
invaluable since the Boston bombing when
I started following them and everyone
would benefit from having the podfather
on didn't we didn't we reach out to him
once or something I think Ian was
talking to him yes or like that yeah I
don't know yeah okay you know I don't
Circle back yeah
JJ says digital currency age digital
Constitution for we the people or we're
walking into digital slavery really
think about what I'm saying
I won't think about it
Ray McKenna says a fun uh you can't
quote section 230 in super chats B my
normal posting account cannot Super Chat
wait wait you can't Super Chat quotes
from section 230.
wow every Everybody send us Super Chat
yeah everybody do it just tie it out
yeah I gotta try this out everyone's
super dead and you know what just to be
sure Super Chat twenty dollars yes just
just to be sure because love the system
give us your money
okay
the Kraken says Tim you are looking at
it wrong YouTube is the employer you are
the employee in at a uh in a at will
state they can fire you without reason
incorrect that is not true it's a weird
analogy to make and I gotta say the idea
that because there's been a lot of
people who've tried making an argument
that YouTube is an employer that you you
Uber is an employer and it's like no it
isn't there's a thing called Contracting
if I'll put this way
this argument was really pushed by the
left because they wanted to strengthen
Union laws the uh the the argument was
in California I think was ab5
that you could if if you freelanced too
much you become an employee so what
happened I think it was SB Nation a Vox
company terminated all of their
Freelancers a freelancer writes an
article and then sells it to VOX media
for 50 200 bucks whatever they're right
I don't know the rate is they then
publish it Imagine This
under that law theoretically you could
you could be a guy with your own house
and your own stockpile of wood and you
start making birdhouses and you're like
I run a birdhouse business and then you
start selling those birdhouses to a
distributor uh oh you've sold 50. now
you're an employee of that shop no no no
no no no I run my own birdhouse
manufacturing business nope sorry under
that new law you're an employee now
because you can't sell that product
anymore that's insane
the way I worked with YouTube is we have
a contractual agreement but I do not
work for them and that is easily
exemplified by they are not our sole
source of Revenue in fact they're not
even the majority source of our Revenue
so that's incorrect they can try and
terminate a contractual agreement but
that will have a negative impact on both
parties and so there has to be terms as
for this agreement I think the issue is
we need to start trading these platforms
like landlords you enter into a uh you
know you own a pizzeria you want a
franchise and open up a new store so you
go to a building and you say I'm going
to rent your building from you and have
my business but there's certain way like
for certain reasons you you could like
you you only can kick us out if we break
these certain rules you can't just
arbitrarily be like terminating your
lease get out the idea that a landlord
could tell people that we have laws for
this reason I think we need laws for
this on digital
I have the opposite approach let the
government get out of this stay out of
it let the free market rain but most
importantly let's let's take all away
all the money and all the tax incentives
that were unfairly given to all the
corporations that of course they have a
handed yep
all right no not to give says mcdees has
come out with an adult happy meal and
there are people who who are upset they
can't get one if the surprise isn't a
beer I think about that people your
team's team's age on ironically wear
Harry Potter shirts people need to grow
up yeah I have like stock generic shirts
I have a bunch of just like mono color
t-shirts that I get in bulk on the
internet
Grand Master Key Lime says so what is
Tim and Luke's excuse for not having
kids programming or extending childhood
nice meaning
um neither
how do you know I don't have kids who's
got like seven kids and and I don't like
to share stuff about my private life and
private life is private that's right and
um exactly how would you know if I did
or didn't yeah yeah like if I had a
child like do you like hypothetically or
legitimately I wouldn't be posting it on
social media for Bezos and Bill Gates to
be able to track and database like I I
don't I don't want any of that private
information out there I got to keep the
teachers unions away from my personal
life Yeah well considering all the
swattings all that private stuff is
going to remain private so you probably
will just not know absolutely yeah we we
have uh look man especially with the
midterms coming up we've got serious uh
security considerations so uh that being
said to answer the question honestly I
have no answer I said I don't that's
nobody's business either yeah oh I don't
know
um I certainly don't uh ascribe to the
views of the leftists who are like don't
have kids because of climate change but
personally I strive to have seven kids
but that's just me
it's like a basketball team with two
backups oh yeah okay with two backups
that's what anyone's do
G at 12 says the monetary system is
basically a Ponzi scheme we need to have
more babies or change it I say make
babies and buy Bitcoin he he and abolish
the FED I drove by it today or maybe
thought about it yes
mimic says on day one musk should
announce that all employees will now be
paid in Doge employees would push it
hard to make it worth more to them
Twitter itself could then promote it
heavily for the same reason and then the
US the the US government collapses can't
pay its debts the Federal Reserve it
gets wiped out and then we enter a
global Doge economy yeah yeah
I see no problem yep
yes
let's see what do we got
Darren Middleton says the North and
South poles are migrating we are in a 12
000 year cyclical cycle a cyclical cycle
huh they call it climate change look
into it the world is going to be
different in 2040 but how different
there's a funny meme about some
scientists who invented some laser or
something and it was like the scientist
was walking down the beach with his wife
when all of a sudden he got the idea for
this particular laser he his wife was
talking and he told her to be quiet for
a moment while he thought and then he
invented this famous like laser device
now used in every home
and then right next to it is the two
muscular dojas and it's a futuristic
city and it says uh Society of women
stopped talking for a few minutes
but we're on track uh historically to go
into another Ice Age right so we might
want to have more and more kids seven
each and uh contribute towards global
warming so we don't go into a nice age
Tyler Adams says Tim do you have a
Jersey Giant hen that you are willing to
sell a batch of dogs killed my chicken
Sunday and it's been very tough
experience with the gore and all I saw I
can't find a hatchery that has any on
hand either we only have four and
they're only like I think 10 or 12 weeks
old so they're fairly small but we are
not selling them but we have many
roosters if you want an official
cocktown rooster we got so many I want
to eat them but Chris doesn't want to
eat them so we're not eating them I
guess because I mean it's kind of that
simple right when it comes something
like the death penalty for a rooster one
veto is kind of like okay well you can't
do it you know it's like I wouldn't I
look at it like the joy I would get from
tasting that that delicious pressure
cooked rooster stew is not as much as
the anger and pain someone would feel by
having the rooster killed if they liked
it I saw Chris eating Popeyes a couple
days ago
yeah but like these are the roosters
that you know he was incubating so it's
kind of like he created them like I I
have no say to say we can we can kill
him Roberto Jr's safe he's got uh you
know he's we're gonna we're gonna build
him a throne and everything but we got
too many roosters and I'm like let's
just eat them they're they're literally
food that's what they do their food and
they make more of themselves you know
it's great but uh Roberto man Roberto's
got like 50 kids
he's
he's been busy huh
Scott private says the optimum
temperature for Flora and Fauna to
thrive at 72 degrees Fahrenheit the
average temperature of the Earth year
round is 59 degrees uh yeah but what
about the equator it's too cold and then
well yeah what about uh cold places like
Canada you'd have more usable land if we
had more global warming there's a lot of
benefits that people ignore
cap says Velma was Hawkeye's wife in the
Marvel movies oh is that for real the
lady who played Hawkeye's wife was Velma
that that that sounds Vaguely Familiar I
literally thought there was a Scooby-Doo
crossover that I missed oh the actress
yeah that that seems to make sense she
looks Vaguely Familiar all right well
there you go and uh okay there you go
Raymond g Stanley Jr says ostrich dude
dude is a normie puts head in the sand
that's actually a really good idea a
superhero whenever something bad happens
he just smashes his face into the ground
and ignores it that's brilliant but he's
got super strength so it's like don't
like when the when the bank robbers see
him and he slams head in the ground
they're like okay don't let him know
we're doing this
go and lie to him and tell him
everything's okay and then you know as
they're looting the bank one guy's like
no one's robbing the bank everything's
fine actually Trump rob the bank you
should be mad at Trump yeah and then
he's down there going rulers
that's a good idea I like ostrich dude
yeah and get Kent on it yeah all right
yeah ostrich dude Vex [ __ ] Kill Rock
Says blizzard did the same in World of
Warcraft they took chromie a bronze
dragon who mortal form is a female gnome
and and then is a new book made her a
male dragon choosing a female gnome form
uh oh
well okay Leroy you know Jenkins you
know how dragons are right they're
always trying to change into gnome girls
yeah that's what dragons do it's a it's
common in a dragon lore you know you
guys should uh should read up on it
Abyss mom says I made a Healer a tank
and in a few months my second DPS will
be born
what does that mean like your first
daughter as a priest your son is in the
Army and you got two kids that are
thieves
they're in jail yeah
do you guys know what DPS means damage
per second
video game thing
yeah RPGs and stuff damage per second
it's basically you know when you're when
you're forming a party you have someone
who heals the group the tank is the one
who's fighting the dragon to take all
the damage and then the DPS are the ones
causing as much damage as possible to
get him down and then I used to play
Rogue in World of Warcraft so you deal
so much damage eventually you take aggro
from the monster because like you're
hitting it too much and it turns and the
tank has to then pull it back off
otherwise you'll die faster ah man good
old days of uh wow wow classic those are
the good old days man
Blake Smith has shout out to the
red-headed libertarian oh wait no he
says redhead librarian oh close enough
well yeah
absolutely
Como Shepard says didn't Lewis Black say
the Republicans are a party of bad ideas
and Democrats are a party of no ideas
Eric Adams comment regarding immigration
there you go
sebby Rose says Mastodon is Lefty but
it's not the only part of the fetiverse
plaroma and misky and peer tube support
a much more broad-minded selection of
fediverse instances you should really
look into look further into the
fediverse I think Ian's working on that
stuff it's a big project trying to
create uh you know infrastructure and
then you can't ban anybody so there you
go
David Toronto says when she was reading
the Pelosi thing she sounded like the AI
girl on the song Masterpiece by
Motionless In White amazing song by the
way huh never heard of it thank you
study about population basically he was
told if we don't increase the population
we are dead why though pretty much
there'll be there'll be not enough
people to reproduce and a lot of the
older people won't have anyone to take
care of them as well yeah so a lot of
the Medicals uh you know things that
people depend on won't be available to
them because there's not enough people
to facilitate that
everyone says a good name Ian for
president 2024 Ian and Luke ticket let's
go who would be the Secretary of Defense
and Secretary of State Tim and Sheamus
would definitely run the New Media
Empire after the old one crumbles
can I be the Secretary of Education then
fire myself yeah absolutely
you won't have a chance all agencies
will be fired under my much
okay let's see uh Action Man
professional hater says Velma is my goo
gaga milky Mommy
huh what does that mean this is a valid
contribution I appreciate it Velma is a
cartoon character well I guess there's a
live-action version of her oh thanks
yeah
taking back toxic toxic says Bugs Bunny
did all the drag first oh bugs is trans
you know yeah there you go that's right
ardwick says regarding Scooby-Doo
Mystery has indeed been solved after 50
years for 50 years we didn't know
velma's sexual preference now we do I
think we all kind of did wow velma's
that would make Velma what how old are
those characters supposed to be
I don't know I I would think twice yeah
so Obama's like 70 something years old
they're just like Immortal yeah you know
what I realized like their car breaks
down a lot
and they conveniently end up in places
where people are trying to lower
property value by dressing up like
Monsters it's like a kind of crazy thing
to keep happening you know and in fact
if we were going to make this make sense
I would actually argue they were in it
the whole time
because it only it doesn't make sense
that they keep car the car keeps
breaking down in the same place it would
actually make sense that they're in on
the schemes and they're selling the
schemes yeah and then turning on oh this
is it yeah they convinced the guy here's
what we'll do you dress up like
Frankenstein you scare a bunch of people
property value drops you can buy the
building but then little do these people
know they show up
and then get him arrested so they get
their names in the paper
clout do they get paid to do this I
don't know is that a component of
Scooby-Doo like does anybody give them
money how they pound it by gas yeah
maybe maybe that's why they keep
breaking down all the time yeah maybe
yeah
I have no gas
maybe uh Freddy is just like a trust
fund kid he pays for everything that's
what I I would That's The Vibes I get
yeah no I bet it's Shaggy yeah Shaggy
because he looks like a layabout well I
I what I was saying earlier before we
went on air about the five colleges
um there's five colleges in
Massachusetts called the five college
area
um and it there's a theory that they're
that the Scooby-Doo family is modeled
after the five colleges you have Amherst
College which is the preppy guy College
you have Holyoke College you have the
Holyoke Mount Holyoke which is the
preppy girl college and you have Smith
college which is the gay college then
you have Hampshire College which is the
stoner college and then you have UMass
which is the party College there you go
yeah that would make sense Scooby is the
party College Scooby's the party College
yep
ghost Crusaders as the actress that
played Velma has been in a bunch of
stuff since more recently she was
Hawkeye's wife in The Avengers films now
that just say it hmm yeah I didn't know
who she was
well there you go hey how about that
all right let's grab some more Super
chats what is this
waffle Sensei says we have to make the
new awesome content ourselves and they
are leaving the doors wide open for us
charge agreed yep agreed
yeah
siani Reese says I'm a writer and love
people watching because it helps in
creating someone who seems real I have
noticed in the writing groups those like
me get overlooked for the sexuality
characters
is that a reference to Velma
no
Joseph Cox says ladybug man check out
David Lopez you want a new character
with superpowers LOL
we look like some let's come up with the
new superpower right now what do we got
um how about uh
ladybug man no way we need a superhero
that's a guy who has the ability to uh
throw
yeah hair oh from his palms that's
horrifying I don't like that hey look
think about Spider-Man like Spider-Man
Spider-Man good yeah so this this guy he
can you know he can fire hair and then
wrap you up and throw you because he's
also very strong for some reason gross
porcupine porcupine man string cheese
man how about the hair comes out of his
armpits though yeah it's not good either
character that see the thing is like
Spider-Man should be firing the spider
webs from his butt
if it was accurate yeah but they knew
that was too much so it's like from his
wrists for whatever reason so we can try
and make you know uh superhero cool how
about a superhero who has the ability to
um blow fire well that's not that's
normal it's like you think of something
original so like he can take his eyeball
out and throw it and then see with it
that's probably done too that's a Roman
myth yeah a guy who has the ability to
move
holes yeah to different areas yeah so
like he can take the the space of a door
by bending space time and put the port
of the door on the other wall but it
still leads to the same place yeah
that's a cool one right that's pretty
cool that'd be like a villain power I
like I like the villains I bet that's
already been done though as Something
Like Bugs Bunny would do he would like
pick the hole up and put it on the wall
yeah they never missed with Bugs Bunny
Bugs Bunnies have a lot of crazy
superpowers yeah he's incredible yeah
all right everybody if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends become a
member overtimcast.com we're gonna have
a members only uncensored show coming up
for you at 11 PM you know what I miss it
follow the show at timcast style you can
follow me at timcast Josie do you want
to shout anything out quicker quicker
quicker
yeah you can go ahead and follow me at
trhl official over on Twitter and that's
really the only thing that I do
yay follow me on Twitter too it's at
d'angeliscori and if you want to help us
in the fight for Education Freedom you
can take the education Freedom pledge at
edfreedompledge.com thank you guys so
much for coming that was great if you
liked their shirt that I'm wearing right
now you can get it at a reduced price
people are asking in the comment section
so I'm going to answer your questions by
being a member of lukeansensor.com you
also get a new video today on Bill Gates
financing digital ID today on
lukonsitzer.com there's a normie shirt
that's available on my Twitter right now
twitter.com Luke we are change thank you
so much for having me Linda very cool
thank you Luke for sure you guys I lost
3 000 followers since Elon Musk is
actually apparently buying Twitter I'm
crushed by this since I know no one
would voluntarily unfollow me you guys
can follow me on Twitter and minds.com
at sour patchless as well as sour
patchlets.me and follow at timcast news
on Twitter for our journalists and news
reporting and then we'll see all of you
over at timcast.com thanks for hanging
out bye guys